like
I'd like to welcome all the members of
the public to our hearings today the
first hearing is 464 prior to getting
into that message for the committee
right here
um when I was a school principal we had
what we call the Sunshine fund and that
was a fund to try and get enough
coffee out there and and where we picked
up the money for that too so we're going
to be wanting to discuss that in terms
of can it if if everybody contribute a
little bit to the plot then we can be
paying off the costs of bringing the
coffee and because that's all on us and
if you're not a coffee drinker don't
worry about it but uh we buy
there might be tea it might be hot
chocolate whatever so uh it'd be nice if
we could just put a little jar out there
and if you have a little bit of
something you might want to put it in
there it can be put in anytime
um so we've also used those monies at
times when we have had get-togethers you
know and and we had to book a place or
something like to have a dinner together
which is a nice thing to do as a total
committee Rick is that the same fund
that where the five dollars goes if your
cell phone goes off during a session
that's exactly right and and I want to
reinforce that
and it's non-lapsing it's it just
continues you're right representative
um
well we have a performance audit done it
I do it and and so at any rate so
um it will be out there uh and you might
take advantage of the time to turn your
phones off right now because if we hear
it going off there's a little bit that
goes in the kitty and we'll discuss what
the rules are going to be if it's going
to be five bucks it used to be that you
had to pay for a meal for us oh and that
was huge dollars so you learned it
quickly to turn it off so with that um
information didn't really need it for
the public but took advantage of the
time so we have 464 on the docket this
morning this is relative to eligible
students in the education Freedom
account program and the prime sponsor is
before us right now I like to well
welcome Erica land representative lamb
to present her Bill thank you Mr
chairman good morning members of the
House Education committee I'm so glad
that I had the opportunity to serve with
you the first year of last term for the
record I am Erica Leon and I have the
honor of representing Dairy I am here
today to introduce House Bill 464 which
expands eligibility for the education
Freedom accounts to a number of
different marginalized groups
we currently offer students and families
which make up to three times the federal
poverty limit level the opportunity to
use a state portion of their school
funding to follow them to an education
option of choice
while many of the students in the
following categories qualify based on
income that is not guaranteed and the
experience of a relatively more
well-to-do student in these
circumstances can be even more isolating
let me give you some examples as I share
the categories
Foster kit children are thrust into the
foster care system for many reasons and
extending the EFA will help a student
who is already attending a private
school keep that crucial consistency
while their world drastically changes
migratory child migratory workers
include field bosses not just field
hands and I for one don't want to
discriminate against the children of
migratory workers who earn more than
three times the poverty level level
homeless child homeless lists can come
catastrophically after a family
financial disaster or a house fire just
as a foster child already attending a
private school should not lose their
school along with their family these
homeless students should not lose their
school along with their home
children of active duty service members
their parents wrote a blank check to our
country up to and including their lives
and we don't know if that check is going
to be cashed these students deserve some
choice
English language learners
our educational system has learned a lot
about teaching most English language
learners but those on both extremes
still struggle very low skilled students
I know these students my mom actually
taught kids who immigrated from villages
in Mexico that had no written language
the standard ell programs don't work
with those kids but being able to
individualize it works sometimes that
happens in the school system sometimes
they need other options and then very
high academic skills students they'd
benefit from individualized immersive
English while they can continue to
achieve their academic process progress
in their native language while building
up both sets of skills so that they can
perform well in English
persistently bullied students if a
student is persistently bullied they
definitely deserve an Escape Plan well
an Escape Plan other than dropping out
which unfortunately happens too often
a child with a disability
neurodivergent children often don't do
well in a standard classroom they need a
more personalized approach to learning
one that can accommodate their learning
differences allowing these students to
take their state portion of funding with
them to a better educational fit will
save the local school district the
tremendous cost of trying to replicate
the environment that is naturally found
at many learning cooperatives
a student with a documented manifest
educational hardship these students are
already leaving their local school for a
better academic fit allowing these
students access to EFA funds broadens
their options and it relieves the school
district of the cost of an out of
District placement
a student in an underperforming school
is defined in statutes schools in the
bottom five percent of the state and
high schools that graduate fewer than 69
percent of students over two consecutive
years meet this definition well I have
compassion for these schools I have more
compassion for these students who may be
missing out on an education those who
want another option should have access
to EFA funds to do so
a student assigned to a persistently
dangerous School
no student should be forced to attend a
persistently dangerous School these kids
definitely need access and finally any
student who's eligible for a free or
reduced price meal I know that right now
these levels are below our income
eligibility but I believe that if a
family is determined to be in need of a
subsidized lunch then they also deserve
to be able to have their State dollars
follow their student
this bill is not a referendum on the EFA
program this bill provides access to
some students who are marginalized and
face challenges
many speak of systemic oppression it
comes in so many shapes and sizes that
no one thing can fix it but this can
extend a branch to some students who
don't fit in the system and they need
out
small learning groups can accommodate
students in a way that a school system
never can
by necessity we build our schools our
curriculum and our schedules for average
students and then we add as many
supports as we can for those who perform
below the level and we hope that those
are performing above will make it
anyways
educational groups of choice and private
schools can meet the needs of student
well educational groups of choice more
than private schools in my experience
but they can meet the needs of students
as individuals unless it's a small
private school honoring what makes them
special and building the foundation that
they need to succeed in life
what I'm asking you today is if these
students deserve to take their state
funding to a different option Foster
kits migratory and homeless kids active
duty military kits English language
Learners persistently bullied kids and
those with a documented manifest
educational hardship children with a
disability and students in low
performing or dangerous schools
I believe that these students deserve
whatever options we can offer them and
letting their state funding follow them
is only fair I ask that the opposition
to this bill tell me and these students
which of these students don't deserve
the opportunity to have their state
funds follow them for Choice thank you
thank you very much representative are
there any questions from the committee
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
aren't these students already available
for cfas
um thank you for the question not every
student is available for these you could
look at a foster student who's come from
a higher income family and was attending
a private school something catastrophic
happens in their life where suddenly
they need to be placed in a foster
family
they've already had their world shifted
we should be able to offer those EFA
funds for them to continue that or
whichever educational option they were
how about the other students
um there are many of those students are
I would hope that our active duty
service members are above the income
threshold those families definitely make
a lot of sacrifice for us English
language Learners are not limited to
just one income group there are some
that make more money and some of those
may be higher performance students some
of them may be lower performing students
and they may need more intensive focus
on English and then separately on
academics so that both can improve and
they don't end up behind a grade level I
have some experience with that since my
mother spoke in uh school and taught in
a school that had a very very high
immigrant population and over two-thirds
of the students were English language
Learners it took a very special process
to get these kids up to speed the kids
that spoke Spanish did a better job but
those with tug log and other languages
that were less common had a much harder
time building up both their English
skills and their academic skills without
having learning losses
thank you for the clarification thank
you further questions
yes representative luno
thank you Mr chair thank you very much
representative lamb for for joining us
this morning
um so um
exactly what's preventing these students
from getting a voucher right now
um thank you for the question not every
student in these categories make is in a
family that makes or makes at or below
300 of the federal poverty level and a
follow-up Mr chair yes and how much is
that
I don't remember the number offhand
um do any members of the can I can I get
a clarification well and at the end
maybe tactical but this you know we're
going to limit it to two questions right
now okay because I believe that's about
140 000 a year it is not that high
unless you have a family of eight or
nine somewhere around 86
000 86.87s I recall
see if you were talking if you were
talking greater numbers you would be up
to a hundred eleven thousand dollars but
that's that's a different category
yes representative could you just
clarify what you just said 86 000 is
which percent that's the 300 percent
thank you
now don't quote me on that exactly
it's a family of four okay are there
further questions for representative
Liam yes representative uh woodcock
thank you Mr chair appreciate it good
morning good morning
um I'm just going back to for my own
notification here on line six of the uh
document on the aggressive it's up to
300 percent what are the currently that
is the current law the current law right
now okay so my question deals so it's
not an expansion of the 300 percent it's
just to that level
um the question deals actually with line
eight and
um where you you had in your bill free
reduced lunch folks uh and those
students uh those entitlement students
have to reapply every every year for
free and reduced categories to be
certified uh most entitlement programs
in the state have to recertify every
single year my question is
if if students or parents or students
who who are now at the 300 threshold and
make the uh appropriate documentation
and their income goes above the
threshold
then as they move down why why should be
why should we be funding that I said at
least minimally recertify every year
I mean I don't understand I don't
understand why we exclude them from
recertifying every year like any other
entitlement program
well thank you for the question and
Health and Human Services we're dealing
with the Medicare Medicaid Cliff problem
we don't want to create a cliff problem
here in the education Freedom accounts
and this is actually the current law I
know at least 12 families myself that
are within a hundred or a thousand
dollars of that and they're worried that
if they need to recertify that the
question is are they going to make
marginally more and then end up costing
their family more by not having this in
order to provide the educational
services that are helping their children
Thrive do we want families to limit
their income so that they continue to
qualify for programs or do we want both
the families and the students to thrive
oh I want to thank you
um
I'm not going to debate if that issue if
we want them not them I do know that we
have every every panel program has a
Line in the Sand uh every driver's
license has a Line in the Sand every uh
can you put that in the form of a
question please where yes yes sir thank
you I appreciate that
um
if every driver no okay um the point is
the point of the question is that why
should any one particular group be
entitled not to create or recreate that
certification every year on every other
entitled program that we all use for
anything it just goes eligible to
ineligible right so this particular
program we say nope you don't have to do
that
um thank you there's another bill that
deals with that but the state adequacy
Grant going to Public Schools is not
limited by income I'm not sure why we
would limit it here either
thank you Mr chair thank you and
clarification on the amount if you had
400 percent of the four family that's
111 000 as I stated if you're at 300 I
believe it's down around 83 000 for a
family for a family of four
yes represent Drive
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question
um what's the current status of
schooling ability for homeless children
and are there high schools that meet
this um dangerous uh standard in New
Hampshire
um thank you currently homeless students
go to the I believe it's either the
school district that they were in when
they lost their home or that that they
are in I don't know 100 but I know we
discussed it and we've discussed it
before
um that's actually a good one to look
into and make sure that these students
needs are being met not just through
efas but through the public school too
thank you
in the high school yes
um the high school is very dangerous
High School
I don't know of any options for students
that are in a persistently dangerous
school are there any that are
yes well are there any currently
designated that way
um I I apologize I did not look to see
if we currently do but I hope we don't
that would be a terrible thing to have a
persistently dangerous School here in
the state but if that does happen it
would be good to give those students a
way out
thank you that that information is
governed by Statute and you can get the
answer to your question if you contact
Doe
further question representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um in in current
um funding for EFA programs there's
nothing in law that would link
um those uh dollar amounts to qualify to
uh inflation levels is there
um thank you for the question that's the
state adequacy aid so that's something
that is calculated separately in the
budget each year so that is something
that's dictated for all students who
attend public school charter school is a
slightly different calculation and then
for those students that qualify for the
EFA so we set that on each year oh each
biennium
adequacy set by the biennium
thank you further further questions from
the committee
yes representative thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question my
question is that a lot of these
categories that you have up here
um would require special services
um and is there anything that a private
school that takes a voucher are they
prepared to and do they have those
services available that ESL students
would need or emotional services for the
bully students
or even going on to you know
students with learning disabilities
that's a that runs the gamut so just
thank you for the question
um this is these aren't vouchers this is
money that goes into account to pay for
whichever educational service provider
is determined by the parents to meet
their child's need so they will go
looking to figure out which one it is I
know a family that's not an EFA program
family but they have a child with
significant learning disabilities and so
they are paying out of pocket for an ot
to work with their student and a student
that was basically decided to be
uneducable through this intensive work
and then Family Support is actually
performing only a couple grade levels
behind and she was essentially
considered a lost cause by the school
system our schools are really really
resource constrained when we have aides
that are coming in to be one-on-one a
lot of that is to try and get things
back into more of a small group adaptive
learning process when you're starting
out in a small group where you have
maybe six or seven students in some sort
of Learning Center working together
those individual differences both teach
the children how to work with with
people with different needs and it also
supports those students that otherwise
would need intensive supports in a class
of 16 to 25 students but in a very small
group that's able to naturally be part
of the educational process I can tell
you not every single student will
necessarily find that provider outside
of the school system but this isn't a
one-way process any family can go back
to their public school if they find that
they're not having their needs met and
so they always have that option of
returning if they cannot find better
services that better meet their needs
and I would bet those families would be
really really appreciative of what the
schools do when they started off
frustrated when they left the school
system
thank you I'd like to remind everybody
in the committee we need to address
questions relative to this bill
uh vfa law is in statute right now
that's not what this is not putting EFA
in statute this is
identifying additional categories which
would qualify uh for the efas let's try
to keep it there
um any further questions for the
representative
thank you very much thank you I'd like
to call forward uh representative Lauren
selig
good morning good morning thank you for
seating me quickly so I can get to my
own hearings um I am representative
Lauren selig I am also a parent of two
kids in the Oyster River School System
and I oppose this bill
um and increasing the eligibility for
um these students there are a number of
items that were listed talking about
special education talking about ESL
these are programs that are already
currently being defunded by the voucher
program
um and continuing to take money out of
our public school system by funding kids
going to programs where there's no
accountability there's no certification
there's no monitoring to ensure that
these children are in fact getting any
of the education that we're
presumably paying for doesn't serve
anyone's purpose currently vouchers
receive uh seven thousand dollar over
seven thousand dollars per student
um as the justification and so if that's
the case I don't understand where the
justification comes to only provide
public schools with four thousand
dollars per student in terms of state
aid
um you know we need to live up to our
constitutional requirement to fund
adequate education for all students
across the state not just pull uh money
for people who decide to pull their kids
out of the public school system as a
parent of special needs child I know
that the private schools in my area
often do not actually provide any
support because they are not required to
by federal law in the same way that the
public school system is it allows for a
significant lack of balance between the
two having also taught in a public
school system where I taught in an ESL
there's an ESL program in my school we
housed 45 different languages
students Thrive when they are provided
collaborative education in those
settings I cannot tell you how many of
my ESL students transitioned into my
regular English classes and went on to
go to incredibly challenging four-year
colleges go into the US military go into
career paths and become incredibly
successful without needing to pull money
out of public school systems in order to
do that thank you thank you very much
are there questions for the
representative representative cordelli
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for being here
um I I think you I heard you say that
um was it ESL programs and special
education programs are being defunded
because of this program I was just
wondering I hadn't seen any information
your source of your information it's not
specifically those programs the more
that we continue to pull money out of
our public school system to send to
private schools that have no
requirements
um and and theoretically public charter
schools that are actually run by private
entities
um the more that we continue to do that
and pull the funds out of our Public
School System the less funding there is
available for ESL programs for art
programs for physical education for all
the rest of the programs that our
students need you have a follow-up
question yes thank you
um
uh I'm just wondering uh I'm not
familiar with any private
charter schools in New Hampshire they're
Public Schools but the public charter
schools but the organizations that are
getting the money are not necessarily
public organizations they are
um
there are several of them and there are
other people who probably can give you
more accurate information than I can but
that are actually sponsored by private
entities there's a new one attempting to
start an Exeter that's called the 1776
Foundation school for example which
um is is theoretically a public charter
except that it's the curriculum is all
being purchased at very high cost from a
private organization
are there further questions yes
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair um being newer to
this committee I obviously have a lot to
learn about the various distinctions so
when you bring up the distinction
between uh Public School versus a
charter school is is the distinction as
I'm hearing it correctly that the public
school is government run versus the the
charter is private organization run
technically charter schools are public
schools as well they're started and
again I'm not that foremost expert I
know we've got experts in the room
who'll be able to answer this better
than I can um but um there are there are
public schools that theoretically
specialize in something
um but they students who go there it
takes money out of our Public School our
our town schools for example to go to
just a brief follow-up so but the
distinction there is is government-run
versus private run is that is that
correct basically I don't believe
they're necessarily private run but
they're run by a um in I think by
interest groups primarily okay thank you
and again I'm not an expert in other
questions representative luno thank you
thank you very much Mr chair
um and thank you very much for your uh
for joining us this morning and offering
your testimony and uh um just a question
are you aware that uh seven out of the
seven out of ten of the lowest
performing schools in New Hampshire are
charter schools
um I I am aware of that I I think it's
yes thank you
further questions from the committee
not seeing you thank you very much thank
you so much
oh
yeah thank you Mr chairman yeah okay
yeah a little bit of cursive training
here yeah I went to a public school I'm
sorry uh I was it was uh low performing
and I struggled
I'm going to set my my clock and um try
and do my three minutes but I I hope
um first my name is Campbell and I
had the opportunity to sit where you
guys are sitting uh for a number of
years two decades ago and interestingly
the the conversations the Dynamics and
the thought processes really haven't
changed that much
um it's uh you know the unions are up
front protesting
one party saying one thing that's a
little off skew and other party's saying
another thing
um so I'm really here to hopefully touch
your heart and touch your mind I think
it's time for a grand compromise to be
made this bill does a lot of good things
by expanding the opportunities
for children to be availed the adequate
the adequate education grant that we're
constitutionally and through lawsuits
obligated to give students
that obligation is not just for students
who are in a government-run school that
obligation is not just for students who
attend a union organized educational
environment
um I had the opportunity to sit in a
subcommittee when I was on this this
thing I had the opportunity to pass
legislation that I sponsored and that
legislation is pretty much the education
funding formula that you're dealing with
today we target eight small communities
I'm from Farmington we're a poor
Community one of the lowest and as a
state representative after I passed
legislation in a bipartisan way we got
over two million dollars more
and back then our budget was about 14
million dollars a year
it was significant
um I want to support public education
education is a great equalizer
but we have to realize that students are
entitled to their adequate education
grant period
I try to pass another bill with an
adequate education grant where we
understood that it was a constitutional
obligation just follow the student
wherever they went it was just that
simple
we missed passing the house by one vote
that was 20 years ago and I'm happy that
over the 20 years we now have you know
education scholarship programs we have
this EFA program and we have a mechanism
under certain circumstances for the
adequate education grant that the kids
are entitled to to follow them
I've also since I was here was involved
in private schools I'm the father of my
children uh I'm Catholic involved in my
faith although probably a wretched
Center
I also had the opportunity this last
year to start a non-profit called Seton
foundation and we started a private
Catholic school after the Catholics go
in our town closed and that school
closed because we fiscally discriminate
against anyone other than a
government-run union-organized school
environment we fiscally discriminate
when I mispassing that bill by one vote
I walked out of the house and two reps
in front of me said I'm glad we defeated
that the Catholics won't get our money
now look I'm not saying that we're
horribly discriminated against but it's
still happening today
we need to have
um
this bill passed because it'll give
opportunities for people to come to
Seton Academy and guess what we have
children's with with ifps we have
children with modified learning programs
they have children's with with second
language in our town Rochester school
district provides Aid to us for any kids
that have an IEP that's current law
you should support this bill and and
widening those environments and if you
were ever going to make a change to this
bill or kill it just get rid of the 300
percent
it's blatantly illegal my daughter
um and her husband have one child you
know so it's 65 000 they make just over
that and they pay six thousand dollars a
year and that's almost that's over ten
percent of their income it's almost 20
of their income and their income is
probably at you know eighty five
thousand dollars a year they both work
long hours and hard days and they make
that sacrifice so these kids that are
just starting out and they have a little
four-year-old that they want to provide
a really good environment because they
know they both didn't do well in the
Farmington School District
that's all they shouldn't have to choose
such a extreme impact on their budget
it's these people just over the poverty
level at 400 or 500 percent of the
poverty level that you're hurting the
most so this bill expands opportunities
for different groups which I think makes
sense I don't think my daughter would
fall into any of those groups so I'll
talk about the next bill next but I'll
wrap up with please support this bill
please you know people on both sides of
the alley have lunch together talk to
each other see if there's a grand
compromise that you can make see if you
can get rid of the income limit and
maybe have a little bit of that
education funding Grant stay in the stay
in the public school I'm not sitting
here throwing rocks in the window at
Public Schools what I'm saying is my
child and my children and future
Generations because if you say on the
current cast and you don't do something
all these private schools are going to
close just like the one that I was
involved in with 20 years they closed
and then there's no opportunity so we've
got to support people to make choices so
that there's Market response for good
educational environments we we had to
get all the licensing we had to get all
the approvals
it's it's a fully licensed public school
that I started
I don't like it when people say anything
other than the truth I think so thank
you very much are there any questions
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you
sorry thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony
could you please explain your last
statement how is your newly funded I
mean newly founded Catholic School a
public school I don't understand that
thank you very much for that question
because I think it's a lot of confusing
when we when we founded the school we
had to go to the Department of Education
we had to meet all of these requirements
to open up what they do label a private
school but our school is open to the
public it's contexted in a public place
it's conducted in a public environment
we have a publicly open available
building anyone can come to our school
this is not an exclusive thing and we
get a lot of kids that are on this
program we have about 30 kids right now
in our first year we have 35 kids
committed for next year and I have a
whole bunch of families that are just
over that income limit that may qualify
under this bill for some of the other
expanded criteria which I appreciate
um that but none of our stuff we're not
unlicensed we're not meeting a standard
we follow all the rules and regulations
of the Department of Education gave us
and we had to get approved and licensed
to operate in the public assay school
just like a daycare or you know we have
a license to be an educational
environment and sometimes it's just like
oh they don't follow all we do and
that's when I say public that's exactly
what I mean what we don't have is Union
teachers and Union aides we don't have a
union environment but we have very I
think a very talented staff and you know
actually the teacher of the year in New
Hampshire is in our school it's a
wonderful thing we we have a very good
environment and it's open to the public
thank you further questions
representative cascaden thank you Mr
chair thank you for my question just
pertains to the level of Education of
the teachers are they all certified and
licensed through the department of Ed
yes thank you further questions yes
representative thank you Miss Mr chair
and thank you for being here and
regarding the school The Seton Academy
um so it's designated a Catholic School
do you know
percentage-wise because obviously in
Catholic schools being Catholic isn't a
requirement I'm just curious as to you
do you know the percentage that are I
would say antidotically because we don't
we don't ask that question whether
you're Catholic or not but I can tell
you of the kids that we have I would say
we're about 50 50 that it's it's a
pretty balanced environment
um my adopted grandson for instance is
not Catholic and his father's
non-catholic but they're in that
environment so I would say it's at least
50 50 it may actually be more kids are
not Catholic but we are a Catholic
school and we don't exempt kids out if
we go to mass you know we have a every
school environment should have a moral
compass you know every government runs
school and I'll say government run
instead of public because there's
confusion on that definition but every
government-run school has a mission
statement they have a set of guidelines
that you follow they have a standard of
conduct that they expect from their kids
as they should
we just have that same thing and then
our our thing we actualize our religious
freedom to bring Jesus Christ into it
and to bring a 2 000 year old religious
tradition into their lives that helps
people have a framework
um that I think will guide them for the
rest of their lives I know it has for me
um I went to public school until
sophomore year and then uh got in a
little bit of trouble and they in the
80s they would send you a Catholic
school if you got in trouble so uh I
spent three years at St Thomas and and
got to explore my faith a little bit
more and it and it changed the whole
trajectory of my life and and that's the
point that every environment isn't a
perfect fit for every student so give
these students the freedom they deserve
give them the opportunity to have these
other
environments out there
thank you for your question thank you
further questions
yes represent Woodcock thank you Mr
chairman uh good morning uh Marvel uh a
question for you guys your curriculum uh
do your students in your school uh do
they take religious education is it
curriculum in the curriculum that all
the religious education is immersed
meaning that we're we're authentically
Catholic environment so we don't
separate it out and say oh in fifth
period you have religious education
that's not the way it works we use
Singapore Math we had a very uh a very
uh detailed curriculum committee a very
detailed curriculum process and we have
a very good curriculum I wasn't on the
curriculum committee but I will tell you
that our Catholic moral values aren't
separated out in math class you know
meaning meaning that that we don't say
there was you know two Apostles met two
Apostles how many apostles do you have
I'm not saying that I'm just saying that
that it's not
it's it's not the right it's not the
right question to ask we don't we don't
say we only study like if you had a
government-run school and you had
Western sieve and you took West and Sid
fifth period it's not like you take
religion fifth period does that make
sense yes I was asking if you had a
specific instruction in your curriculum
what you're saying it's integrated
through all your courses
uh we have religious education
curriculum absolutely so we might be
studying the New Testament one day we
study a lot of Latin we study a lot of
different types of prayers we do
catechesis of the Good Shepherd is is in
the Pre-K level
um you know I can talk to you a little
bit more about that thank you so within
your curriculum thank you Mr chairman
thank you very much uh yes represent
Allison oh thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question all right you
started off by indicating that the
unions were protesting out front of this
building which unions were you talking
about
um I don't know which unions they belong
to
um thank you very much thank you for the
questions Nancy thank you very much for
your testimony thank you all very much
okay
good morning good morning Mr chair and
members of the committee thank you for
having me I'm opposed to HP 464 and um
many of my reasons also apply to HB 367
and I thought I'd spare you having to
hear me twice so
um many of my comments aren't
specifically about the exceptions that
HB 464 is wanting to add
or the specific categories but about the
whole idea of expanding the program at
this point
um
first of all I'm wondering what is the
justification for expanding the program
my when uh earlier this year the
commissioner of Education
um said quote it's exciting and
encouraging to know that New Hampshire
families now have the opportunity to
determine the best educational Pathways
for their children he was referring to
the new numbers that had just come out
from the EFA program yet so he stressed
that they now have a new opportunity to
determine best educational Pathways but
in fact
over the first two years of the program
only 694 students
who were in public school left public
school for this program 86 or 87 percent
of the students who took efas were
already in private or home school
without these public without needing
public subsidies so really we spent uh
22.8 million dollars to give 694
Children Choice the other people already
had Choice they'd already exercised
choice
uh
also I feel like this is pretty early to
be expanding a program that's only been
in existence for a year and a half
um
there are a lot of questions that are
hard to answer this hasn't been a lot of
transparency about many different
aspects of the program I'll for instance
I'd like to know why those 694 students
did leave public school what was their
reason and how are they doing now have
their issues been addressed
what kind of academic progress has been
made by all of the EFA students over the
last year and a half
the Bill's sponsors want to get this
bill sponsors want to give EFA students
they want to give efas to so-called
students at so-called low performing
schools
without regard to income but before they
do that shouldn't they determine whether
the private schools that might educate
these kids are better performing how do
we know what data do we have on that I'm
not aware of any
it's a scholarship organization making
appropriate determinations as to which
expenses to reimburse
has anybody else looked at that it's
those are very difficult decisions to
make
and I know that when the does rules
about this were in front of the Del car
committee the attorneys there felt that
that was an awful lot of perhaps
unlawful level of discussion to
um the scholarship organization is paid
10 up to 10 of every uh every uh expense
that it approves
I have I I don't want to sound like I'm
suggesting that anybody's doing anything
uh nefarious but somebody needs to be
watching that other than the scholarship
organization itself it's public money
it's 21 22.8 million dollars so far and
the commissioner has said that uh it's
likely to double next year
is um is it scholarship organization
calculating its fees correctly what
safeguards are in place to prevent fraud
by parents I imagine there are some but
are they sufficient who knows have we
has anybody assessed that
why have only six percent of the efa's
gone to students with disabilities when
18 of the students in our state have
disability our special needs students
why has the fa money gone so
disproportionate lead to to religious
schools rather than secular schools
have any EFA students given up their
efas
um can we turn to public school and if
so why
have any EFA students been denied
admission to any private schools and if
so on what basis
and then even expelled from private
schools and if so why
these are just some questions that
rattle off when you think about a
program this big and you wonder who's
watching it well the legislative
eversight committee was appointed to
watch it they were supposed to monitor
implementation and report back they met
once to organize they met a second time
last March and as far as the public
record shows they haven't met since the
statute required them to file a report
by last November but they didn't
and the only as far as I know the only
other oversight that's expected is an
LBA report they were supposed to be
doing an audit next sometime after next
uh October I believe it hasn't happened
yet nobody's thought that as I
understand the legislature didn't think
it should happen earlier because there
wasn't enough data and there won't be
enough data until the program's been
operating for a while it hasn't happened
yet why would you expand a program this
big in any way whether by adding
categories by changing the income level
eligibility without first having
somebody outside the program actually
assess how it's doing whether it's
actually doing a good job or whether
whether the students in it are doing
better because they're in it whether
they're doing worse we need to know the
answers to these questions before a
program like this should be expanded
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions
yes represent Cass Cannon thank you Mr
chair
um thank you Miss well for your
testimony
um
in listening to all of this I guess my
question would be and I don't know if
you know where this data would be
available
but I know that all students in a
district have options to take a class
take a course get into a CT program join
a club join a athletic team within the
public school system which is locally
governed
um
but I just wonder if that data is
available because that is funded locally
um and an example is when I was a
teacher in a middle school Catholic
School my husband was a public school
science teacher and my students in
seventh eighth grade walked over to the
public school for science because
Catholic school did not offer science
and I would just be curious as to how
many students are access accessing
anything that the Public School District
offers because in my 50 years experience
that is what happens kids like to be on
athletic teams you want kids to be
social parents have always had school
choice
and I think that's a great thing I think
they should have it
but those services that are offered in
the public sector are offered to all
students and I wonder if you know where
that data might be
that shows students on scholarships and
how many public
or city-wide or district-wide services
do they access even if it's just one
class or one program or one team you
know if that's available students who
are taking afas yeah and I I really
don't know whether it's available or not
I just know that that it feels to me
like a lot of information is not
available and it may be available if
somebody would go out and collect it but
I don't know I you know I would I had a
few questions here and there about other
data about the schools and I contacted
the Department of Education and they
said oh ask this you know as a
scholarship organization and I've sent
some emails to scholarship organization
have gotten nothing back I don't know
where you get the information I would
think it would be public and right but
um but I I really don't know and maybe
it is public and I just don't know I
don't want to sound like I'm no expert
I just don't that would be a good thing
it would be a good thing and and I agree
that parents have already have Choice
um you know 694 students took this
50 000 were eligible
parents are choosing they're making
choices they're choosing public school
by and large thank you are there
questions yes representative I just want
to thank you for taking my question good
morning good morning
um you made a comment I just want some
clarification you said something about
their 694
which is about 13 of those who and you
said they're the only ones
um
exercising Choice the ones that are
going from public to private so the
other 87 percent are staying
but are they not exercising Choice
sometimes a choice can be to stay where
they are which is what this is allowing
some struggling families to do
no I agree that they were that those
parents are exercising choice I was
referring to the commissioner's comment
that now that we have this EFA program
uh families now have the opportunity to
to determine the best Pathways for their
children well those 87 percent had
already made that choice before we had
an EFA program so how did the AF Pro AFA
program give them the choice they had it
already they had already exercised the
choice and they didn't need public
subsidy to do it apparently that that's
what I was referring to thank you
further questions representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much Ms Wilke for joining us this
morning
um it's been referred a couple times uh
during testimony this morning that that
the commissioner has made several
comments one of the comments he made
during a close-up uh this past weekend
uh was with respect to um uh fraud in
the EFA program and and the commissioner
said that he's reviewed certain
materials and is assured that there's no
fraud in the program as has been seen in
other states and I was wondering if
you've had an opportunity to also review
the materials that the commissioner is
referring to
materials he is referring to I noticed
in the rules for instance that if
parents get are used the efas to get
computers and other technology and
internet service they can't it has to be
used 51 of the time
for Education the educational
needs of their child
I don't know how you
um I don't know how that's been
monitored I don't know if the
commissioner has gone into homes in fact
I don't know where's where's the
information to find it if that's
actually happened I want to really get
us back to the nature of this bill when
we're talking about the EFA and fraud
that has nothing to do with the
additional categories which we're
alluding to in this bill so let's keep
the questioning
On Target here please
you have a follow-up a follow-up please
thank you um is there anything in the um
in the in the bill here
um which which obviously is an amendment
of the um EFA statute 194 F1 uh that
would um uh um make you feel that um
that that unlike in other states New
Hampshire has better protection against
fraud
um I'm sorry I really I'm not really
sure what you're asking could you say
anything so so give given the fact that
that the commissioner said that there
has been fraud in other states and that
there's none in New Hampshire is there
anything specific to this bill or this
or the statute in New Hampshire that
would lead you to believe that yeah
there's um there's something different
here in New Hampshire nothing anything
I've learned about uh other states
implementation of these programs
compared to New Hampshire so I haven't
seen anything like that okay thank you
thank you further questions represent
Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um we just heard testimony that alluded
to possible discrimination and EFA
funding against disabled students noting
that while 18 of New Hampshire students
have a disability only six percent of
EFA funding has gone to disabled
students but this bill on page 2 line 12
would appear to be designed specifically
to remedy that by opening efas to all
disabled students can can you speak at
all to the that apparent dissonance
there
well I I would think that uh parents of
students with special needs are probably
spread I don't know if they're spread
evenly throughout the income levels I
doubt that they're mostly wealthy
um and so I would assume that if you if
you're at 300 or below eligibility
um it would still be that among that
group there are still 18 of students who
are have disabilities and yet the
program has only been serving six
do you have any Source relating to that
below 300 income threshold also has the
same no I don't I just the only
information I have is with that
Statewide how many thank you thank you
further questions representative Tanner
thank you for taking my question and
thank you for being here testifying
um with disabilities uh the private
schools and the non-public Schools are
they required to follow Ida for example
if a child needed a wheelchair or an
elevator uh for that particular building
or special services are they required to
provide those that's my understanding
that they're not that parents give up
the right to um in to have an IEP all
the services that would be in an IEP
provided
thank you further questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
good morning good morning thank you Mr
chairman I am the director of latitude
learning resources which is a homeschool
Learning Center a non-profit Center in
Derry New Hampshire our students are
homeschoolers and we have approximately
20 percent of our families that use the
EFA program or a scholarship of some
sort to take part in our programming
among all of our students on a typical
day we have up to 40 percent who have
some kind of a neurodivergent learning
or a disorder like anxiety or trauma
so we see quite a lot of students who
are not neurotypical or do not have I
guess typical family experiences or
typical learning experiences
in a given week we offer about 70
classes our ages are 4 to 18 for our
students
for this bill there are two
classifications of that would expand
offerings to the type of students that
we have
the first is for disability and as I
mentioned we have up to 40 percent of
our students on a given day who would
fall into that category
so the other one is because of bullying
we have quite a number of students who
have left public schools because of
fitting in
um we even have had bullying from
reported from
teachers or administrators amongst our
families
so I'm going to tell you about two of my
students one his name is John I'm going
to call him John that's not his actual
name he came to us and
he had been in an auto accident when he
was a boy a young child
he was put in this public school sent to
a special classroom and he was punished
for
symptoms of his accident that resulted
from his accident he came to us two
years ago and can only participate for
part of a day
at that point he was a full home
schooler over the course of two years in
our program he was able to improve to
the point where he was assisting
teachers with their classes
another student
is on the opt excuse me the autism
spectrum
she her parents went to her local public
school to try to get her special
services in an IEP she was denied at our
program because we're small and Nimble
we were able to take care of her needs
no problem
so our program has met the needs of a
lot of the students who were
I guess in consideration for this bill
so I'd like to thank you for your time
thank you very much are there questions
yes reps in woodcock
just one here um just some clarity here
on your home School Association right
because you said your chairman of The
Homeschool Association there's
and you're saying that the students come
to you so is there a structure or brick
and mortar structure where they go yes
we have a facility in Dairy okay so it's
a
another home school it's a private
school it's not a school we cannot call
ourselves a school according to State
regulation we're a Learning Center okay
food
you're just a place where people come
exactly so to explain our program just
for clarification families sign up for
one to four days per week for their
students to attend classes for a full
day the students choose four classes per
day and because they are homeschoolers
their parents are in charge of their
learning program they just come to us to
as a supplement for their homeschool
learning thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you very much other further
questions yes representative Hall
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh you mentioned that
20 use efa's currently with this bill
how would you see that changing
I am not sure how it would change
because we are at capacity for our
program
I'm imagining that other programs like
latitude learning would emerge if there
are more more students in need
yeah thank you thank you further
questions yes representative cascadden
thank you Mr chair and thank you for all
the work that you do to submit and
provide support to those individual
students my question is and you
mentioned
um bullying is prevalent and as you know
um and sometimes a problem in a lot of
places uh but based on that
is your Learning Center required to
complete a school safety data report
that other schools have to submit to the
state it talks about safety of students
suspensions bullying incidents we are
not a school so we do not have to so as
a learning center or an EFA
no efas are individual correct they are
individual yeah but we are an approved
vendor for the EFA program okay thank
you
thank you further questions
representative cordelli uh thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you Ms Osborne for
being here
um we've heard testimony
um about
um
non-public schools and discrimination
um specifically I think uh in relation
to children with special needs
um does your Learning Center
discriminate in any way
absolutely not we do our best to
accommodate the needs of families when
they come to us thank you thank you
representative you had your hand up yeah
thank you very much Mr chair do um do
you collect data on bullying and other
um um student uh discipline issues
So within our Center we have our own
metrics that we use we do our own
reporting but we are not required to
submit our reporting to any state agency
as we are not a school yes well is it
possible to share that reporting with
I would be happy to speak with you on an
individual basis but I do not want to
reveal any data from our families as
their active families and we have a very
small Center so I don't want to
discriminate against those families
yes representative Balboni
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm just curious when
you say that you have the opportunity
for them to come one to four days how
many students would be in your facility
at one time and how many students do you
serve as a whole thank you for the
question so we have over 100 students
come during the week and at a on any
given day we have a between 40 and 60
students so some students come for one
day a week some come for four days a
week it's totally dependent on what the
family is willing and wanting to do
so yes just a quick follow-up um so when
you have those 40 students in the center
at one time what is your ratio of a
instructor or parent to student at that
time
it varies depending on the age of the
kid but
I'm trying to do a quick calculation in
my head our largest class is 20 students
and we have two teachers in that class
plus we have backup teachers and staff
who are able to help out some of our
representative Cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question as an approved EFA vendor do
all of the staff at your school have
criminal checks done before they work
there
so we background check anyone who is not
a parent we
parents who teach are generally known
entities with us who have been with us
for a long time who are part of our
original group but anybody who comes
from the outside absolutely they go
through a background check
follow-up parents who are teaching in
your school do not have a background
check but they are teaching in your
school
yes with their kids there at the same
time thank you
are there further questions from the
committee yes represent Belcher
thank you thank you Mr chair just to
clarify your your program is not so much
a school in a traditional sense as it is
a a center where parents can bring their
children to homeschool them collectively
an environment that becomes more
efficient is that is that sort of a
correctly about it
you could say it's efficiency but I
don't think that's the reason why most
parents come I think it they want their
children there for social opportunities
for learning in areas that the kids
might have an interest that they're not
capable of teaching at home or because
some kids prefer social opportunities or
social learning
so efficiency does come into it but
that's not the primary motivation
thank you thank you representative
Ellison oh thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question you mentioned
that you do do background checks is this
the same process that the public school
uses to background check teachers and if
not what what is the process for
background checking somebody in your
school I am not familiar with what the
public schools use but we use a National
Organization to do our background check
so it's a a state and National Check
well yes uh could you provide the
committee with some information on that
organization that's involved in doing
background checks I yes the name of the
organization just changed and I can't
remember the new name but after I'm more
than happy to thank you other further
questions
that's it thank you very much thank you
have a good day
Wendy
so all right
um just introduction my name is Wendy
Santiago I am a mother of one child I am
a graduate student of clinical Mental
Health
um
so finding school for my son has always
been difficult because instead of being
on an artistic Spectrum he's on a gifted
spectrum and he's very gifted
um I say finding a school for him was
very difficult because unfortunately New
Hampshire doesn't offer an accelerated
programs for children that are
accelerated
so I I did homeschool him for quite a
little for up to third grade
I did choose to send them to a public
school here in New Hampshire
mainly for social skills and for other
skills that you know I thought would be
necessary for him
during that time in that in that school
he entered at third grade
after being called to the office saying
that we're having educational issues
with your child because you just
completed almost two months worth of
work in a week because he's accelerated
he was put in a fifth grade classroom
he was doing absolutely wonderful
until mid-school where he became bullied
physically abused
to the point we had to go to the
hospital
he couldn't walk for a little bit
emotionally scarred
concerned that the threats of one child
the Brenda gone
was very real to him
it was to the point where I had to make
an escape plan for him that he ever felt
scared that he had every right to go
over to Casa which was located on the
foreign
concerns
and the non-responsive of the school
staff whether they they tried or not it
didn't solve the issue I had to pull him
from that school
I didn't know where to bring my son
except to re-home School him at home
which I did
and that is when I found out about
children's scholarship fund prior the
EFA where now he successfully at a
um his testing scores have skyrocketed
he's in eighth grade currently but since
his third grade and currently
um where he's at he's been able to
succeed the school has a zero bullying
tolerance the school has suspended
students for bullying there it does it
doesn't you're just suspended it doesn't
happen in this school it's not tolerated
when I say that his testing scores have
rocketed his knee while testing as well
as his Iowa testing both suggest the
same he is at a 10th plus grade level 13
plus and multiple of those levels he is
above
um he's an eighth and a half ninth grade
math level which is all above his level
he was he had the opportunity to go to
high school this year if he wanted to
um but I allowed him to make his own
educational choice and he chose to stay
at the school that he's at and I think
that's important to understand that
bullying has a huge aspect
on how children learn
and when you're talking about vulnerable
children
that come from
backgrounds that we have in this house
bill
it only makes it very difficult for
those children to learn
or be accepted
it's hard when a child comes home
and has significant bursitis and a need
because a child decides to throw him to
the ground
ripping his clothes
embarrassing him taunting him
harassing him choosing him out to harass
him
I mean we have state laws that are
against that and if I recall correctly
it's RSA
466 that talks about harassment
unfortunately when I go and I ask for
help under that law for my child somehow
he's exempt from that
when I go to the school it's somehow
okay for this to be happening
so without the help from EFA and without
the help from children's scholarship
fund my son would continue to be at home
and not being able to accelerate to who
he is today and I'm very proud to say
because of the less stress that he has
at school not only can he focus on his
current schoolwork but he's also
currently a student pilot
and he's very proud of that and he's can
only give thanks to
all the yeses that you've given
positively to these programs and I ask
that you continue to say yes to help
other students
to move forward and out of these abusive
situations and into in a situation that
they can learn and Excel these are our
children's next this is our next future
these are people who are going to be
sitting in your chairs making decisions
and I think it's going to be very
difficult for children to rise up and
work or go into any other field after
school if they're continued to sit in a
situation of abuse and neglect from our
school districts in regards to bullying
and I'm not saying all do but this
particular School my son went to was
I'm sorry thank you very much Wendy I
appreciate it are there questions yes
represent McDonald thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for your testimony it's
very moving and so are you saying that
if we were to pass this bill it will
increase the physical safety of our
students because it allows them to have
that choice to if they are bullied which
is one of the categories a spill would
expand to they have the opportunity to
be in a safer environment
I'm saying that bullying is not
prejudiced against certain income levels
all income levels
have children in that have been bullied
and I feel that if we can raise this to
a higher income level that then those
other children that right now are not in
that income level can have that same
opportunity of having a safe education
thank you yeah thank you further
questions
now see thank you very much for your
I
have a I won't call this person thank
you Mr members of the committee my name
is Michael O'Brien um I'm with party
strategies here on behalf of aft New
Hampshire
um Deb how's the president of agent you
have to come up here today so I'll do my
best uh not to embarrass the
organization as I said at this table
um I'm gonna not read she sent in
testimony I will not read it to you as
you can be to yourselves I just want to
hit a couple points uh that we think are
important
while looking at voucher EFA programs
whichever one we want to call them and
looking at outcomes which uh someone who
spoke at this table before talked about
not knowing the outcomes in this state
of how these students are doing once
they take the fa there have been studies
that have been done that talk about
outcomes for students who take vouchers
throughout the country so I'm going to
highlight just a few of them here
in 2008 the Federal Reserve Bank of
Chicago so that's the best research to
date finds relatively small achievement
gains for voucher students most of which
are not statistically different than
zero
a 2016 study of an Ohio private school
program which is targeted to students
from well-performing schools or
economically disadvantaged conducted by
one of the four most conservative think
tanks the Thomas Foundation Thomas
Foreign Institute and funded by the pro
voucher Walton Foundation found after
students have fared worse academically
compared to closely matched peers
attending Public Schools
a 2018 longitudinal study of the Indiana
scholarship program found that
low-income students who switched from
public to private school using a voucher
in the 2011-2012 school year experience
worsening math achievements throughout
their time using the vouchers compared
to students who remained in public
schools
and the 2019 study in Louisiana Voucher
Program found that after four years
doctors who have performed noticeably
worse on state assessment State
assessments than their Public School
counterparts uh and same in a 2017 DC
evaluation
um
representative Iowa introduced this Bill
said something that we actually agree on
together
um
which is that our schools I came here
she said uh she referred to my cash
maybe not cash strap but that was the
sort of the point of the what that she
was making
um
we should be funding our Public Schools
public dollars should be funding our
Public Schools so that students who have
uh IEPs or other problems or and I'm a
father of four uh with a uh my second
child who is neurodivergent I understand
that this is a real thing
um
should be funding them so that they can
work with all students that's what
public schools are set for and these
Studies have shown that they already do
better than the voucher counterparts
when given Voucher Program money so
that's really the Highlight they wanted
to do here
um I'll leave it at that because she did
say more again you can read her letter
um but I hope you take any questions
thank you for your testimony
representative dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question did I hear you
correctly that you said the 2008 study
was the best research to date and do we
have will we get information on these
studies I think and if not I will have
her attached I think in her email she
sends you attached to all the studies to
the to the testimony all right so the
first part of my question was did you
see the 2008 that was one question in
2008 they said their best research to
date so and then there were more studies
that happened later than that okay thank
you
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair you provided some um evidence from
outside of State based on uh outcomes uh
looking at the the academic differences
between public school students versus
voucher or private school students
but are there also not other measures of
outcome besides solely looking at
standardized academic testing and
further who is in a better position to
judge those outcomes is it is it us
sitting here in a room in Concord or is
it parents
well I mean I think you know as a parent
you're you hopefully sitting down with
your kid and talking to them and seeing
what they're learning every day and you
know experiencing that with them I think
that's really important
um and I'm not going to sit here and say
the standardized tests are the best way
to judge academics but they are way too
judge academics and I think
um we can certainly use we should use
all the tools that we have and that's
thank you are there any other questions
Michael thank you very much thank you so
much
good morning sir
good morning and uh thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the opportunity to provide testimony
here today my name is Sarah Scott and
I'm the director of Grassroots
operations with Americans for Prosperity
here in New Hampshire and on behalf of
Americans for Prosperity New Hampshire
and our activists all across the state
uh we ask that you support House Bill
464 to expand eligibility for the
education Freedom accounts program I
don't want to repeat too much of the
testimony that's already been given here
today but since the education Freedom
accounts program was launched in 2021
we've seen over 3 000 students who have
taken advantage of that this opportunity
to really find an education that best
fits them
unfortunately this opportunity doesn't
exist still for thousands of students
across the state and this could really
be a life-changing opportunity for some
of these specific at-risk categories of
students like those in foster care
English language Learners the bullied
students children of military families
and uh these categories are already
vulnerable populations and we should
really be giving them every opportunity
we can to succeed in kind of looking at
this bill I did some research on some
other states that have passed similar
programs a lot of other states have
specifically outlined these categories
as eligible for Education Freedom
accounts so I looked at kind of some of
the reasons that these parents have have
opted for this and in I think the state
was Arizona they were one of the first
states to offer it to be a specific
categories and specifically looking at
some of the students with disabilities
and one of the stories that I was
reading was actually a parent who was
explaining that her child was getting
greater services with their local public
school they enjoyed the the teachers
they liked the program the only issue
they had was that her child's Peak
learning hours were from 6 a.m to 9 A.M
it seems like a very small window just
meant you know most kids are going to be
in school from eight o'clock onwards but
her student learned best from six to
nine and unfortunately the public school
couldn't accommodate that we can't
always open the school for just one
child at that early hour so she was
looking to take an EFA specifically for
that case so I think a lot of times we
think that if a student is taking an EFA
they must have an issue with the current
Public School sometimes that issue might
just be timing and I think there are a
lot of instances like this that we can't
really accommodate for every child so we
need to be making sure that we're giving
the opportunity for these families to
find the option that does work for them
so I know this is a just a couple of
very specific categories but I think
it's really important to give these
students the option to find an education
that best fits them and make sure that
we're not in in Concord here saying that
a one-size-fits-all system is what works
but really giving it to the parents and
the students to decide what works best
for them
so I know you guys are running a little
long here so I'll just wrap it up by
saying that uh we ask that you support
this legislation
thank you very much sir are there any
questions
not seeing the hands thank you very much
good morning Brian good morning thank
you for hearing my testimony my name is
Brian Hawkins I'm here represent
representing Nea New Hampshire today and
um like Mr O'Brien I'll be handing in a
letter from our president Megan uh so
that you'll uh but I'll just speak into
that and summarize that we're here in
opposition to House Bill 464 and later
on uh the subsequent bill because this
would greatly increase the amount of
funds directed toward our school voucher
program by expanding the eligibility of
the program and the P the bill appears
to do so by eliminating the income
eligibility from among a variety of
categories of students so a few
overarching uh concerns about expanding
the program generally first
we believe that school vouchers
undermine the state's commitment to
public education by diverting scarce
resources as was referenced in earlier
testimony away from our community
schools these are the ones that we all
invest in the ones that serve the vast
majority of our students
and whose funding model is one that we
still have to fix though we still have
to work on that and we feel that that
ought to be the priority for the
legislature first before we are
expanding a program that we're still
unsure of what expanding that program
means both for student outcomes and for
the costs of the state
um
uh as was mentioned earlier
um there have been a number of recent
studies that uh private school doctors
do not improve academic achievement and
we have no indication of that here in
New Hampshire so we I have I have not
seen any studies about the program here
only the ones that were referenced in in
other states and uh when I hand in the
testimony we have citations for all of
those studies uh that you can that so
that you can look at it they include
studies from Louisiana Indiana Ohio
which I demonstrated that those
experiences actually produce worse
academic outcomes from their peers so
I'm not saying that New Hampshire has
that but uh we ought to be looking at
that before we go go ahead and expand
this program also some other studies
from longer standing programs like the
district Colombia
these this the pro the EFA the EFA
program that we have does not hold to
the high uh accountability and standards
our Public Schools do we have rigorous
academic standards which we've been
talking about in other committees and
those standards are carried out and and
held to account by locally elected
School boards
um not not the case with the program
that we're talking about expanding today
um and specifically to the to the point
about the expanded groups uh you know
our concern is that they are not going
to receive the necessary services that
um they would otherwise receive
um in in our Public Schools uh you know
some of our small rural uh property poor
communities
um these schools rely very heavily on
state funding and we have not adopted a
separate Revenue source for this program
and and we are committing more money to
it with this bill and and the subsequent
bill that you'll hear later on this
morning so uh
many of us who whether you support or
oppose efas agree we need to do more for
districts like like these
um and that we're not diverting precious
funds away from the schools schools that
need it most
um
just a couple of quick references from
some earlier uh and and again this this
is in our written testimony so I won't
read it I won't read it but the the
current EFA program does require
students with disabilities to sign away
uh their idea rights and so that that's
in the law uh there uh there's also uh
with respect to uh you know bullying
that our law only applies to public
schools and so
um that there aren't not remedies
for families under under a private
school setting
um
and then I think I'll just close with
One Financial note I know we're in the
policy committee so
um you know the department put forward
this is the as RN our understanding is
that this is the proposal that the
department has put forward I believe
this is what they brought to the
governor's budget request
uh hearings and so
uh and in those requests
um you have a program that has gone from
estimated being just several hundred
thousand dollars in in in in in in the
first uh year to now a request of over
30 or nearly 30 million a year and so I
uh it's unclear I don't know whether the
department will be testifying but one
question I think the committee ought to
uh ask of the department is are those
requests uh
accommodating the policy proposals in
this bill
or are they just to maintain the current
projections they have under the law as
it is I think that's an important
um item for the legislature to
understand
well I have further comments about 367
but
um I'll I'll leave those to my to my
written testimony I'll close there thank
you represent Cordell you have a
question yes thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you Mr Hawkins for being here
um you mentioned diverting money from
public schools can you identify any
public schools that have not gotten the
money that were promised to them
according to state law sure uh maybe I
should clarify so when when I say
diverted money uh I think we've heard a
lot about a lot of needs that our
schools have not only at the hearing
today but I think in every hearing you
have in this committee and so we feel
that it would be important to
direct those public resources to those
needs first before we are expanding a
program
um like this so I hope that clarifies
some follow-up questions yes thank you
so really you're not talking about
diverting money you're talking about the
need for a new education funding formula
is that am I correct I guess diverting
in the sense that you know our education
trust fund was was meant to so to uh
support
um a public school
uh our public schools and
um that
with the law the way it's structured
right now uh that also that is also
supporting the EFA program
um without any additional Revenue
sources and so
um so that that is what I'm referring to
when I when I'm saying that the
resources and funds are being diverted
thank you for the question represent
Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question do you know any school public
school in New Hampshire who's not fully
funded in special education at this
point because of the funding
uh I hear this is an issue that uh
we I think we hear it quite frequently
that special special education costs uh
whether it is from federal government or
the state government is not uh you know
the support could be much greater uh in
order to to to
um to carry out the mission
thank you any further questions
representative like us
it's my understanding from thank you for
taking my question that from various
testimony that we've heard that part of
the issue with um
special needs and providers is that
there just aren't enough and that
schools even though they may have the
funds are not finding the providers and
so I'm wondering how
um
disallowing students or parents to try
to find those
providers on their own which maybe they
have to drive two and a half hours to
how that is harming the public schools
who can't take their kids maybe two and
a half hours
oh thank you for the question I think
that goes to the the point about the uh
we we
the state could be doing uh a far more
significant sorry I'm I'm also looking
past the speaker here uh
in uh in terms of uh so supporting our
schools
um overall I mean one of the we we've
talked a little bit about the Staffing
shortages in schools and that's
significant whether it's you know
teachers to paraprofessionals uh some of
the uh folks are really key to carrying
out uh IEP programs
um
we it is hard it is harder to uh and one
of the keys to that I think in finding
the limited amount of staff we have is
having additional programs that not only
help feed the pipeline of people who can
take those roles but also uh additional
funds so that schools have greater
flexibility in increasing their wages
and I think I think that's where we
ought to be looking at rather than
um you know an additional
uh 30 million dollars a year out of the
trust fund to to
um to fund uh the program we're talking
about today you're welcome and one last
question represent Belcher thank you Mr
chair
um just to try to get the heart of the
issue a little bit in speaking to the
the concern about public funds being
directed to
um perhaps non-public education
um obviously we live in a Multicultural
Society and I guess my question is
should we be looking to
um to allow one part of that culture
perhaps a politically dominant part of
that culture to have a monopoly on
public funds going to
them or should we be trying to meet the
needs of other all sort of multifaceted
cultural groups
by allowing public funds to flow in ways
I think that
um
I think that is important we meet the
needs of our of our students that's
obviously number one
and I think we and I think what we have
through some of the points I was making
earlier about funding I don't think
we've necessarily realized all of that
because we could be doing a better job
of of funding the community schools that
we have the ones that we all have a say
in whether we're parents or not parents
you know we have a say in what that
curriculum looks like we have a say in
who are the elected officials that
manage that program
um and I you know that's I feel that
that's not the case with the program
that we're talking about here especially
when we're using
um public dollars thank you very much we
have one more person to testify uh thank
you very much Brian thank you have a
good morning
good morning uh to Mr chairman and
members of the committee and thank you
for allowing me to speak today
um I understand that there was my name
is Louise Spencer and I'm um co-founder
of the Kemp Street Coalition which is an
all-volunteer Grassroots organization
um I understand that there was testimony
today
that the teachers unions were had
organized a protest outside and I just
wanted to clarify about that point
although it would make sense that
teachers would be outside in support of
public education
they're mostly in the classrooms today
so the folks standing outside were
primarily from the Kent Street Coalition
and just they're members of the
community who are concerned about our
public schools and making them the
strongest can you speak to the bill
yes well I was just speaking we were
standing outside opposing the bell hb464
and its companion bill
um so and I also just wanted to speak to
the testimony provided which was very
moving about a child being bullied in
the schools and that in support of the
bill HB 464.
that should not have been anywhere at
any time in any school public or private
in our state and I would ask the
committee instead of diverting public
funds to private schools which in fact
this bill these bills do do that the
attention would be better spent on
addressing the issue of bullying and
solving that to make sure that no child
is ever in a position in the school
where they're thrown to the ground or
they're are not able to learn because
the school is an unsafe environment so
please take up that issue and spend the
time instead on that instead of making
it harder for our public schools to do
the job that they're there to do so
thank you very much thank you very much
are there any questions for our
not saying thank you very much okay
uh there there's been no pink cards put
forward so I'm going to close this
hearing at this time we're going to take
a five minute break before we start up
foreign
okay we're going ahead now with the next
hearing which we have on the docket for
this morning it's HB 367 this is
relative relative to eligibility of
students in the education Freedom
account program and I'd like to welcome
representative leckis who is the Prime
sponsor of this bill
thank you for the record Alicia leckis
Hillsborough 38 Hudson and Litchfield
and oh we'll get the card I will give
you the card I always forget if I'm
introducing the bill I need the card too
sorry
so how did this bill has come to be
it just came okay when we were working
on the efas I remember talking to so
many parents who were so excited that
finally they were going to have the
money the means to provide for their
kids the education that they felt that
they're you know that their kids weren't
currently getting and that that they
needed
and they were very excited and then
when the EFA became finalized and the
300 cap was put on it which wasn't
originally in there it was originally
every child was supposed to be educating
every child as a previous speaker had
mentioned
um
the
money that the state provides is
supposed to provide education for every
child in the state
and so here you know so the idea in the
efas is it was to go to Every child in
the state and then the cap got put on
and there were parents who were very
disappointed to find they were just
above that cap and still and this is
what I heard this is sort of a
paraphrase of what I heard from lots of
different parents in their own words but
it was basically once again the
government takes and takes from us and
doesn't give anything back we're the
ones that always suffer and that's the
middle class they pay the most taxes of
anybody whether it's Federal whether
it's their property taxes whatever they
end up paying the most taxes total
and they're the ones that always get
left behind
don't make enough money there's
scholarships
there's programs the individual schools
have scholarships there's scholarship
programs there's all kinds of things
available and If you have money you can
just pay for it
the people who get hurt all the time are
the middle class they pay they pay they
pay they support everybody else and when
it comes to them and their kids they
can't afford to send their kids to that
private school they can't afford to pay
for that special needs teacher who's the
they pay their taxes
there was one parent who said to me what
are my kids garbage she was very upset
she was listening to the testimony
um I think it was Senate testimony at
the time and the person was going on and
on about our private school kid you know
our public school kids and she's like
my kids don't fit into the public school
what about them do they not count are
they not people are they not deserving
of an education too
I pay my taxes she said
why can't my kids have the same
opportunity of Education
just because they're not going to the
public school why are they being singled
out she was very upset
so I thought well let's at least I mean
as you know I have another bill to get
rid of the cap because I believe that
every child is entitled to that state
money
as according to the Supreme Court
however many years ago that was but I
thought at least at least let's reach
out to those Middle School I mean middle
income people who can't afford the
education and don't get the scholarships
so I was trying to figure out what is
that number and at first I was and I
asked various people from the state and
various other people what is that number
and at first I was told 600 percent and
then there was a deep dive into well
they thought 550 would probably reach
all the parents
middle-income parents who couldn't
afford to send their kids to school well
I was I know that people are all upset
about paying for middle-income people
and paying for non-public school people
and so I dropped it to 500 percent I was
being conservative compared to what I
was told it would actually you know who
to try to Encompass that middle income
group
of parents and students in our state so
that's
that's basically what this is about and
I'm open to questions thank you very
much are there questions for
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I think we clarified
earlier this morning
that the current 300 percent is around
eighty thousand dollars
500 would take that uh cap up to what
I don't remember exactly at the moment
because they're changing what that those
numbers are I had calculated at one
point it was like 111.
um but my understanding is the
the federal government is changing
numbers and whatever so I'm not sure
it's no I think I think it is published
yeah well I
I haven't done the current calculation
based on the code
I think and we we had the same bill last
year and I think when we were dealing
with it last year I believe correct me
if I'm wrong but I believe it was about
a hundred moves it to about a hundred
and forty thousand dollars is that do
you remember that no I remember 111 no
but let me clarify for you please a
hundred and eleven thousand dollars for
400 percent of a family that was for 400
if you're going to a family of five
um if you do some really quick math and
I'm just trying to do it myself at 130
137 000 roughly
okay yeah okay yeah and my and my my
point to that is this is based on the
federal poverty level
which the area we live in is pretty
expensive and the Southern Tier of our
state is very expensive and compared to
the South
it's it's like twice as much to live I I
know people who moved from here to there
and they're paying half as much now in
rent they buy you know the houses cost
half as much Etc so I'm saying that our
average cost of living here is a lot
higher and so going by the federal
poverty level
um that's a nationwide average and we
are at the near the top of that average
and so
you know that is not taking into
consideration the expenses that people
actually have to pay here and especially
with the housing
um
whatever you want to call it the
increase in housing costs I think those
again the middle income are hard hit by
that because those are the neighborhoods
that went up up most in uh value and
pricing because that's where people are
really trying to move to and there were
bidding wars over houses so and I know
rents have gone up for those who are
renting so I'm so it's not unreasonable
that we're paying more I mean we should
be paying more or giving more here
um especially as I said in the Southern
Tier of the state I know it's very
expensive and that includes Manchester
um it's very expensive to live and so
basing it on the National Poverty Level
I think it's kind of artificial to begin
with thank you further questions from
the committee
yes representative thank you Mr chair
thank you representative uh for taking
my question
um my concern this is related to my
question my concern with having a cap at
all is that it could encourage people to
earn Less in order to go below that cap
so I don't know how that would pertain
how does this bill relate to that issue
well as I said I would prefer no cap
but we have a cap and so to that end I'm
trying to at least capture some of those
people who are paying their taxes who
are working hard who want the same
opportunities for their kids and they
just can't make it and yes any cap is
going to have that
waterfall Cliff effect
um
I'm trying to push that out to be able
to get as many as parents who really
can't afford
um to send their kids to the where
whatever it is their kids need and I'll
tell you a school stamp can we have
another question here so we can you know
move on a little bit here we need
are there further questions from the
committee
perhaps in Woodcock yeah I thought I saw
your hand up thank you our Channel
thank you for taking my question I said
okay from yesterday
[Laughter]
the initial uh EFA bill will put in if I
recall a language I don't have I don't
have my law book here to flip through by
the way we won't get you a a yellow one
how about that thank you thank you
that's the old one thank you chairman uh
you know the old book that we don't have
here for the new people uh in that
particular BFA it the intent was to
provide options for uh students from
parents who made under the 300 poverty
level is that correct actually when the
EFA started and when it first came
before our committee there was no cap
okay but I mean the law that went in the
law that went in was a compromise and
put on a cap and because of the cap we
are seeing parents and kids being harmed
this bill is to try to uh remedy that
the representative of the lab it
indicated that the the 500 percent that
you put in is 138 according to the New
Hampshire okay thank you 38. the the uh
me income public income in New Hampshire
2022 was 83 8 000. as 55 000 difference
between immediate income and the five
percent and I would suggest to you that
Conway the media income because they
have it broken down by Town calling
immediate income is 57.6
so when you're saying that this bill is
going to 500 percent uh poverty level
and we're now up 138 000 that's clearly
not what the bill was intended for to
start with but the the building law so
I'm just trying to figure out how your
bill aligns with the intent of the law
to help low-income families we are
talking about an income of 138 000 which
is fifty five thousand dollars more than
the media income well at the time when I
came up with that number the median
income was a hundred and that's where I
think the 111 was is hitting my brain
that was the median in the state average
um somebody wanted one son 111 is 400
representative correct so 400 would hit
the median income
no maybe at the time it's not been there
where are you getting the media family
of four the New Hampshire 2022 census oh
we'll see and I came up with the numbers
prior to this oh yeah
but my question is my I I will stick
with when the EFA was come up with when
it first hit when we tried to get it
passed there was no cap because it was
not intended as just for low income that
got changed
that's what went in luck I'm trying to
head back towards the initial
priority which was all kids in the state
not just lower income because lower
income have other options
middle income do not
thank you for the further questions no
other questions from the committee
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair I I know that we're
hearing obviously concerns that uh money
would be flowing to wealthy families who
can afford it and we can have that
ideological discussion another time so
my question to you is in a time when you
go to the shopping the grocery store and
you you might be paying ten dollars a
dozen for eggs is a hundred and forty
thousand dollars a year for a family
wealthy or do you think that's middle
class that was my point that according
to the people that I talked to at the
state in various
people
600 percent would would Encompass all of
the middle class and so I was being
conservative with 500 percent and with
the way prices are going up now no we're
not we're not talking wealthy we're
talking
you know trying to get the middle income
people the people who cannot pay for
these special and as an example
a family has a number of
and what they were doing before
because as we know there are very few
you know the the resources are slim and
there are only certain specialists
around in a lot of schools yeah they
have them and yeah the kid has an IEP
but no they're not getting the services
because they're not available
she found somebody who was quite a drive
away but she could only afford to take
the oldest kid twice a year that was all
she could afford she did get she her
family does just barely meet the EFA
requirements she now all the kids are
being able to get
the need the the
um
their needs met and each one has
slightly different learning disabilities
and the specialist has been able to
address each of the kids and she can go
more than once a year and all the
all of the kids excuse me are actually
getting the services that they need
which they could not before the EFA
thank you thank you very much are there
further questions from the committee not
um I'm struggling with the penmanship
cursive here on this and
and that must be me it says cities on
the bottom
it's a c a r i s a r c u r o w
Crow
oh okay
okay
sorry about that I see that
um a long time since I've been here uh
so very similar topic
um talking about education Freedom
accounts again and uh the eligibility
for that so uh as I said before my name
is Sarah Scott and I'm the director of
Grassroots operations with Americans for
Prosperity here in New Hampshire and we
are here in support of this bill
um so this legislation is really to
continue expanding the program so that
every child in New Hampshire can have
access to the education that best fits
them we've heard a lot of positive
stories coming out of the current
education Freedom accounts program of
families who are now able to access an
education that they couldn't before
we're seeing kids that are happier
succeeding more in school academically
um and I know we don't have enough time
to really collect a lot of data on this
yet but the the initial stories coming
out of it seem overwhelmingly positive
but uh in all of this there have been a
lot of sad stories as well there have
been a lot of stories that I've heard
from parents who to say I know you've
been involved in this legislation what
is 300 what does that mean
and when you explain it to them
they go through the numbers and they
have come to me and said I'm over that
so what what are my options and the
tough thing is there aren't options
um if you can't figure out how to make
it work in your current budget you're
really your option is your current
status quo the toughest story that I
think I heard I just wanted to highlight
here was from a mom of four kids and she
said you know unlike a lot of families
whose income dropped during covid hers
actually went up it was going to be a
temporary increase in income it wasn't
something she expected over the long run
so she knew that she would be back down
to her current income the next year but
that temporary boost in income actually
put her over the limit by I know it was
under a thousand dollars I think it
might have been under eight hundred
dollars such a small amount and when
you're looking at the the sacrifice that
these kids are then going to have to
make they have to wait another year
another year in an education system them
that isn't meeting their needs whether
they were being bullied whether they
were unable to get the resources that
they needed for their education or
whether they just fit better in a
different learning environment
a year for a child is a really long time
and we shouldn't be penalizing kids for
the fact that their parents made eight
hundred dollars too much to get the
option to find a better education and
this isn't just a one-off story there
are a lot of families like this who
don't meet that 300 percent but they're
by no means the the rich and the wealthy
there are a lot of families who are
looking for other options and just
trying to find the best education for
their child and I think we need to be
making sure that we're empowering all
Granite State families to find what
works best for their family so I just
wanted to close by saying that we ask
you to support this legislation and
continue allowing these families to find
options
thank you are there other questions from
the committee yes representative Luna
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much Miss Scott
um you had mentioned um about the
success stories and that I think you had
said uh there's approximately 3 000 um
uh students in the efe program right now
can you tell me how many were in their
attending their public school full-time
the year before they uh did the EFA I
believe from the Department of Education
that number is 27 but I could be off by
a percent or two okay I believe it's 27
okay thank you so so
um to your testimony
um most of these students
north of north of 70 percent were were
already attending either private school
or home school and had exercised some
Choice prior to receiving taxpayer funds
uh thank you for the question so yes
they they were but those sacrifices for
a lot of families weren't sustainable
there were a lot of families especially
during covid who either for concerns
about the learning environment for their
child for health concerns uh made really
significant sacrifices to take their
kids to a different education option and
a lot of times those weren't sustainable
so during covid some parents were able
to work from home and home educate their
children but that wasn't really going to
be an option moving forward so I think
that those numbers are not necessarily
reflective of the kids that would have
typically been in a public education or
kids that would otherwise be able to
afford that okay thank you further
questions from the committee thank you
very much I'd like to invite up David
Trumbull
good morning thank you Mr chairman thank
you committee I'm a citizen of where and
I come as representing myself here I'm
opposed to this bill because I believe
that the funding mechanism is is not
appropriate I don't think it's legal I
ran for State Rep this fall I did not
win which is why I'm sitting here today
though but in doing this I did research
onto this bill I looked up the education
trust fund and as you know it says
clearly that the fund shall not be used
for any purpose other than adequate
education grants to school districts and
Charter Schools I looked up the
legislative history of that bill it is a
150 page document that was written 20
years ago a bipartisan and bicameral
report House and Senate alike in a
distinguished group of people from the
community they looked at in this bill
entirely funds going to solve the
problem of the property Rich towns and
the property poor towns there is not a
single mention of there of giving money
to parents or to private schools the
money has to go to the school districts
for the town schools and Charter Schools
under that law taking the money from it
for this purpose even if it's a worthy
purpose even if every testimony you've
heard today is true it's outside of the
purposes of the original Law there's a
fiduciary duty to manage a trust fund
and that is the legislator's duty we
have violated that trust because that
money should be returned to the trust
fund so that the children in Claremont
and Franklin and where in Pittsfield and
Rochester and Allenstown and all the
schools that towns that don't have
enough property tax base they should be
getting the money from the education
trust fund so that their schools and
their charter schools are adequately
funded if we want to do this additional
funding it should be funded through its
own funding source and then if it's
going to be something where the the
sponsor said every child has a right to
this money from the state then they're
basically being a state actor and all
these private schools should then be
required to meet the requirements of the
state that puts on on a public school
for instance RSA 19338 which says no
person shall be subject to
discrimination in public schools if
we're going to solve problems in public
schools by basically having private
actors become public schools then they
should be forced to also comply with
these rules with of no discrimination
the last thing I want to say is I've
heard the commissioner say this bill
will save schools money that doesn't
make any sense because if you have towns
Port property towns that have five or
ten percent of their children go off to
these private schools they're going to
be getting less money from the state but
they still have fixed expenses those
fixed expenses don't go away so the
operating money that will be available
for the remaining students will be less
per student the rich towns can make that
up they can go back and raise their
local property taxes and provide a super
education for their children but the gap
between the have-nots and haves in this
state will be widened by this bill if
you don't restore the money back to the
trust fund where it was originally
intended the Supreme Court looked at
this constitution 20 years ago and all
those Claremont decisions and said this
money should be going to the property
poor towns we as a state heavy duty duty
to do that we have not done that and
that's why we have all these problems
that we're dealing with today we've got
to go back to the beginning fix that
problem first and this can be a
secondary approach but we have ignored
the original problem that's my opinion
thank you very much thank you very much
are there any questions
not seeing thank you very much you're
thank you representative
and I'm glad that my name is spelled
better or maybe just had a good memory
um so I'm Campbell and um you know
still former rep here in House Education
and I do support this bill and I'd like
to clarify things because I was heavily
involved uh oddly enough in the bill
that is education funding and what we're
talking about is the adequate education
grant and the state has an obligation to
provide that to students who are
receiving an adequate education parents
have a compulsory obligation to make
sure their kids are receiving an
adequate education
so the institution that I helped start
provides an adequate education for about
30 students right now that's what we do
it's a public service that we provide so
that parents can check the box that
their kids are receiving an adequate
education the bill before you limits
their ability to get that adequate
education grant unless they make less
than 500 percent of the poverty level
I support this bill I think that's a
good compromise Bill yes I too would
rather see no limit because I think you
have a fundamental and I will say to you
that when I put in things like average
members in Residence is how you
determine the amount of the adequate
education grant the funding going to a
town like Farmington but when you get
the grant as a school district it's in
attendance
so you live in a town your town gets you
counted in your education funding money
but you money goes only if you attend
that school
and that was with purpose and import and
I'd like to say oh yeah this 20-year
vision of you back in 20 years to have
this argument or maybe it took me 20
years to clearly see what the law really
says the law says we have an obligation
to provide funding of x amount set in
biennium every two years and by the way
it's pretty much the same as what it was
20 years ago
we kind of just set it at that 3 700
level every biennium and hasn't
increased in the last 20 years
and I think that's a problem but that's
not what this bill is about but what
this bill is about is for
um adequate Educational Services that we
provide that parents should get that
money because they're fulfilling that
obligation so if you really want to look
at what you have you have a
constitutional issue here you know
people say oh is it illegal illegal here
I am similarly situated I have a student
myself I'm over the income limit and he
attends a school and gets an a private
education
but because I'm over an income limit my
student doesn't get the adequate
education grant so although as a parent
and as a student we're just the same
getting an adequate education as anybody
else
that book that they hand out to you when
you get sworn in has some stuff in it
I'm not a constitutional expert or
Thumper but basically you're entitled to
be treated equally under the law
if you have an income limit people
similarly situated are not being
treatedly equally so when I said earlier
I want to challenge your mind I want to
challenge your heart I want you to at
least be open to the possibility of
doing something that's right doing
something that's constitutional doing
something that makes our society fair
and equal
I should not because I have a bigger
wallet than the next guy say that my
religious freedom and my choices are
dependent only upon the size of my
wallet that's not what our constitution
says I have a right to choice and
religious freedom regardless of how much
money I have and when people say to me
oh you can exercise that right as long
as you have money to pay for it that's
fundamentally flawed
the adequate education grant should go
where to the institution that's
providing the adequate education and
right now under law the mechanism to do
that is the EFA account because if it
was to a public or a government-run
school it would go to the town and then
the town sends it to the school district
but since we don't have a big town that
represents all these different
homeschoolers or Charter Schools or all
those different opportunities get the
adequate education grant the law
provides for scholarship organization to
manage those funds and have an account
for those kids and those accounts get
distributed just like education funding
gets distributed four times a year and
comes to our institution most of our
kids are getting that Grant which by the
way our tuition is six thousand dollars
the grant doesn't cover the whole six
thousand dollars those people are still
contributing they're still doing stuff
so you have this fundamentally thing
about not treating people equally so I
don't want the whole Community to blow
up like I made the confident about
unions I apologize didn't mean to be
inflammatory but I do want you to
consider this the other way you could
fix it if you're going to have an income
limit whether it's 300 percent or 500
put it on public schools
I'm a rich guy why shouldn't I pay the 3
700 bucks for my kid to attend
Farmington High School I make more than
300 of the poverty level
and then at least it's treating
everybody the same
so I think you have to do one or two
things and what I'd like this community
to consider doing and whether there's an
appetite for subcommittees for these two
bills I'd be happy to see if there's a
compromise that can be made and I do
believe there's a compromise to be made
because I've done it we can do it we can
work together it's possible you don't
know what's going on in my head up here
I have things that you will love
the other thing that you can do is if
you're if you're if you're gonna deal
with this issue and you're going to
admit that there's a constitutional
issue because you're treating people
similarly situated differently and
that's what we're doing
then send it to the opinion of the
justices because both sides of these
arguments I mean my goodness there we
have a committee that pretty much we
know how people are voting I was you
know on the committee I knew I could
count noses before we even had the
hearing and I certainly think we could
do that today
so let's send it to the opinion of the
justices let's ask them that question
because one side believes adamantly it's
wrong and shouldn't be done and the law
says only government schools and the
other side or at least me I don't know I
can't speak for the side says that it
can be done they're getting an adequate
education just like Catholic Charities
gets government money for providing
social service programs
schools whether religious or otherwise
they're homeschoolers if they're
providing that adequate education they
should get the grant that's as simple as
I can put it this bill at least brings
it for people like my daughter and my
son-in-law who make about 90 000 a year
they'd be right on the cusp of that 400
percent and I wouldn't want it to be
that close so I think 500 percent
encapsulates these young kids making 22
an hour making a sacrifice of six
thousand dollars a year to send their
kid to a school and there's all kinds of
families doing that and if and if we had
we're built to have 60 students and I do
believe that we would get to 60 students
if you lift the income limit or you
lifted it to 500 and then if we had that
number of students and the people paying
we could meet our budget because right
now you know where our budget comes from
right here
and I don't mind doing it I ain't gonna
do it forever
I can't afford to do it forever I'm not
that rich of a guy
but I didn't want to see no Catholic
Education in the Tri-City area and the
Rochester region because we're closing
schools left and right and we got to
stop closing schools by stop
discriminating against who gets their
adequate education grant that money
belongs to the parent and the student
and that's what the state law says we
have an obligation to fund an adequate
education quickly chairman Dover
we pass education funding and we had a
stop Gap it meant that if you're you're
funding targeted aid went up more than
20 in one year you couldn't get the rest
of the money
we had to put that in for compromise and
education funding right
over sued and said wait a minute we have
more than that we have the students to
overrun that lawsuit because they were
adequately educating more students so
their money they should have got
extended the cap so we already have
court cases that say if you're educating
the student you get the Grant and I
think they should again I support
government-run schools I support all
education in New Hampshire I just think
if we have a robust uh community of
opportunities our educational level at
the secondary level can be just as good
as our educational level at the college
level the college level in the United
States is very robust very effective
best in the world the secondary level
where we rate down with third world
countries or you know not at the top
there's a problem with the structure of
how we do it we shouldn't have 90 plus
percent of our kids in the
government-run school and only a small
percentage in private other schools that
they choose I think if that was more
balanced 50 50 where do we want to be in
20 years that's what I'm asking you
having looked at where we are 20 years
later I think that's the question we
should all be searching our souls and
saying instead of worried about this oh
gosh it's public it's mine where are we
going to be in 20 years and I hope that
um thank you all I know I'm passionate
about this so thank you for your service
all of you everybody thank you very much
are there questions from the committee
Naseem thank you very much
um hello I'm Kate West thank you for the
opportunity to provide testimony today
I'm here in opposition to this bill
um I believe that we don't
often apply this same logic to other
public programs and community services
and I think it is a dangerous precedent
to set if I came to you and told you
that I didn't think the fire department
served my family well because we live in
a more rural area and I don't trust that
the fire department is going to come in
an emergency for me I would like you to
use public funds for me to put a
sprinkler system into my home
you might say well how about we look at
what the issue is with the fire
department and try and solve that
problem right if I told you the police
department same thing I want a private
security system in my home I want you to
divert tax dollars so that I can protect
my home in the way that is best for my
family
that's not how we do public programs and
com and Community efforts we sit
together and we say why is this failing
you how can we make sure that this
service does not fail you
this is how I feel about our public
school system I do not disagree with
folks that say my student is being left
behind and underserved and I would like
the public school system
to be held accountable for that
I disagree with the idea that diverting
funds away from our public schools and
putting that effort into private systems
is going to help solve that problem in
our Public Schools I think that our
Public Schools need
more community support and
to be invested in further in order to
close those gaps in order to make sure
that the students that go to public
schools every student gets the education
that they deserve another issue that I
continue to hear is the definition of an
adequate education and as was
stated earlier
you know our public schools are held to
specific standards on what that
definition is that private
schools are not helped to those same
standards so in essence using tax
dollars to provide a private education
that is not under the same standards
it's there's no way to say hey this
really is an adequate education if we're
not holding folks to those same
standards as our Public Schools so
instead of diverting funds away and
giving that money to private citizens to
use as they see fit in order to provide
education for their children I would
like to see us work with our public
schools and make sure that they are
adequately funded and have the programs
that they need in order to serve all of
our students
thank you thank you are there any
questions
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair I'm just trying to
understand in the same manner that
you're understanding the the point that
you made about public services and how
this is not
how we typically administer a public
service because when I think of police
or fire
I think of if you call the police
because somebody's broken into your home
the states being the police comes to
your home
and they don't they provide an
individualized service on that occasion
they don't arrest you because that's
just standard practice when you call the
fire department they come to your home
they don't if you have your house on
fire they don't put a ladder up to take
a cat out of a tree they provide an
individualized service to you at your
home
um
so I'm trying to understand that the
manner in which this is so Divergent
I live on a hill in a rural community so
it's my belief that the fire department
won't be able to get to my home in time
I don't trust that service is adequately
serving me I would like to instead use
public funds to have a private solution
and put a sprinkler system in my home so
I don't have to be dependent on that
public service that is
a problem okay that public service
should be serving that home in a rural
community that's 20 minutes away we
should find a solution to make sure that
that fire does get put out rather than
saying you know what we hear you so
here's some money for you to solve that
problem on your own as a community we
should be solving problems together
thank you yeah
yeah thank you through the questions
representative Tanner
thank you for taking my question
um just as a follow-up on that
um
does your fire department your police
department and your particular community
um do they go through a budget review
and accountability review uh every year
and then send a worn article or an
article to the town I think where we are
now when we're talking about police and
fire here I I see
what you're trying to parallel but let's
talk about this bill please and the 500
percent increasing it to the 500 from
the 300 that's where we need to okay
I'll ask a question on that do you do
you see that raising this um or even
providing the initial funds for the for
the education Freedom accounts has the
kind of accountability by elected
officials both academically and fiscally
further questions
Nancy thank you very much
I'd like to invite uh Kate Baker Demers
so much to unpack today I'm Kate Baker
Demers I'm the executive director of
children's scholarship fund and I was
dismayed though this morning to hear
that you've had hours of presentations
from the Department of Education but
they haven't given you any of those
types of reports the fiscal reports the
vendor reports the expense reports we've
been reporting to them quarterly so I
did decide that I'm going to create our
own annual report and I'll bring that to
you I don't know how long it will take
me to put all the stuff together that
we've been reporting to the Department
of Ed but my apologies that you didn't
receive a full presentation with all of
those pieces of information a lot of the
questions that people asked today would
have been answered in advance and so my
apologies for that what I would like to
address though is the actual data around
this 500 percent of the poverty line
um 334 children applied for the
education Freedom accounts that were
over the income limit
um by ten thousand dollars so they would
fit into this group
um less than about 95 of them
were less than 10 000 over the limit so
they've got that's your people that were
either one dollar over or ten thousand
dollars over
172 children would fall into the bucket
of one dollar over to twenty thousand
dollars over so that's the group of
people that you're looking at you're
looking at about few hundred children
that you would add I also brought the
guidelines with me I it's funny that I
I'm chuckling to myself that I'm I'm the
only one that brought the guidelines so
I can make a copy of it for you if you
want you guys or I can just read it to
you
um in essence most of the people that
this would impact are your single parent
with one child so the income limit for
the single parent with one child at 300
percent of the poverty line is 54 000
and so it's those single parents that
are making sixty thousand who tend to
struggle with any kind of realizing any
kind of different opportunity for
themselves because they just don't have
the disposable income to do it and so it
seems like increasing the income limits
to 500 percent would income impact
mostly those people that are one parent
one child because that's where the
income limit is quite low so the
difference between that single parent at
with one child at 300 percent is fifty
four nine thirty that would raise it
really all the way up to and I'm getting
a little old so you have to excuse me
91 500 and so that does capture a big
group of those
single parents who otherwise are
excluded from the program those are the
ones that that hurt my heart a little
bit that I wish I could help that I
can't and so I think this does that the
other thing to consider is
um I'll just tell you one one of these
income stories
a young little boy
with autism he was having
um outbursts he was in essence dangerous
to the people around him in the school
um he lives with his grandparents
because the opioid crisis his
grandmother was concerned if in the
school he kept being a discipline
problem and having these violent
outbursts that he would endanger the
people around him she pulled him out
with one of our scholarships and moved
him to a Montessori School where he was
less stimulated because he worked
independently using those Montessori
materials after three years of doing
Montessori he was more well adjusted and
wasn't having any more of those violent
outbursts
um the again Elizabeth's grandparents
they got a roof leak on their little
house and the grandfather is a
tradesperson he went out and did work to
make money to fix the roof and that put
them over the income limits that's why
in the education freedom account they
said that once you're in the program you
stay in the program and I know we could
debate that you know all day whether we
like that or not but the reason that
they did that was this type of scenario
where this family went over the income
limits for one period of time and then
went back down to the income limits you
know I know some of you may like this
program in this room and some of you may
not like the program I do see it as part
of the public education system that is
is public education and and
infrastructure and in that way I agree
with some of the testimony that we've
heard today that the income limits don't
necessarily make sense right again when
I go to the door of the public school
they don't say are you 300 the poverty
line I agree with the testimony that
it's the adequate education money should
be for all the children in the state
particularly since the Claremont rulings
and those those Supreme Court rulings so
I would love to answer questions about
this I understand that many of you have
questions about how the education
Freedom account operates what the
families have been doing their test
scores all of that information is
available at the doe and I'm pledging to
you to build you a package that answers
all of those questions so I'm happy to
answer questions about this instead of
that and if you would just allow me the
time to get that to you I would
appreciate that very much
thank you very much Kate you're welcome
questions from the committee
representative miler
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Burris for being here I'm happy to see
you representative miler in person I'm
glad you're well uh thank and I thank
you for your commitment to do to provide
that information my pleasure because
frankly the transparency of this program
is is I thought you would have a
presentation from the doe as because
again I consider as part of the public
education system I thought you would
have had our presentation already and
I'm not gonna you know say maybe they
intended to do it still to come and we
just didn't get ahead of it and so yeah
I'll definitely get you all the stuff I
mean quarterly reports we send them so
it's pretty easy to you know pull it put
it together it might not be beautiful
but I'll do my best to get that you know
maybe give me a month or so to build
something for you guys but thank you all
the questions that were asked today were
quite simple to answer
so so yeah so so my question okay great
thank you for your my pleasure pending
report the question is is that in my
understanding and my as we've dealt with
this on this committee is that the
original intent of the EFA program was
to provide funding for underserved and
impoverished parents
this program notwithstanding your
comments about the Gap that this would
provide sure this does ex this does go
beyond would you agree that does go
beyond the original intent of the
program so the original Bill didn't have
income limits I think the original bill
on this education Freedom account is to
allow every child access to that
adequate education or meet our
constitutional obligation to provide
every child the opportunity for an
adequate education I think what you
might be feeling representative Miler is
my my personal intent in fact is to help
low-income families and kids that are
bullied or that need a different
alternative and so when I talk to you
about it in my mind that's why I do the
work personally is to help low-income
kids and kids that possibly don't fit or
need to go to the Montessori school for
a little while or something like that
and so I don't want to conflate the two
I think the scholarship programs intent
is what you're describing but I I think
the education Freedom account was along
the lines of ensuring that every child
has access to their adequate education
grant since its per pupil funding I
think that was the intent of the
education Freedom account follow-up
please yes I do believe that Senate bill
193. so now going back to 2018 exactly
okay which was which was the original
yeah when it was first brought forward
by the Senate I do believe it did have
an income I think the first one was for
special needs kids
group Glenn's Glenn representative
cordelli wants to answer your question I
think
okay absolutely yeah yeah
tax credit stuff and let's not go there
right now okay fair enough but I think
the first
education savings account Bill may have
had income limits thank you I don't I
represent Tanner
thank you and thank you for offering to
do this report I think it will be very
enlightening totally
um I'm wondering there'll be things in
it you don't like though I'm sure oh no
there'll be things you like and you
don't like but I'm I'm happy I'm fine
with that right yeah sure
um I'm wondering if
um now that the now that this program is
off and running and you've got uh you
know it's you've got a number of people
uh taking part of it and that the
scholarship fund gets the 10 uh cut that
perhaps
um have you considered using some of
that money which you may not use because
the initial startup now is already gone
yeah to give out special scholarships or
grants to these particularly
difficult situations where there's a
child with autism that doesn't fit into
a regular school system uh you know
somewhere on that line to use that
rather than expand the income level I
love your question because you
understand my intent representative
Tanner which I really appreciate about
you
um I raise money right now for kids that
don't meet the income limits the
challenge is remember they're both hard
ceilings and so if a family doesn't meet
the income limits we can't help them at
all we would have to raise that money
and I can do that sometimes but again
when you go around just raising money
people only give you a certain amount
right so I'll always run out of that
money regardless but I do appreciate
your question and the fact that you
understand that my intent is really to
help kids that need something you know a
bullied kid or or whatnot so thank you
so much for the question and I'll keep
raising money forever and helping as
many kids as I can for as long as I can
without question yeah
thank you representative Luna
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much Mr Demers for taking the
question uh we've heard this morning
that there's about 3 000 ish uh students
32 22. right yeah thank you you're
welcome
um
that was January with my question yeah
thank you and uh in that uh
approximately 75 of those um students
were were not attending Public Schools
prior to uh taking the vote so I have
that data let me continue with my
question please so 75 of those students
were not attending uh Public Schools
um and and having no no expense to New
Hampshire taxpayers 25 approximately
were attending their public schools and
receiving an adequate education I was
wondering if what where these students
are
today if you can tell us of the
3200 approximately students how many are
now uh and I'm talking about EFA
students are now either attending
private schools public schools or our
home in a homeschool environment so I'm
going to do it from a general because I
don't have that memorized in my head I'm
pretty good representative Luna but I
want to address your first question
first the first part of the question
where is to meet every child in the
state is a liability to the state okay
they are all kids that could happen
first I only had one part to the
question and it was of the 3200 students
where are they yes where are they now so
about half of the children are choosing
a brick and mortar building school and
then about half of them are multi
providers meaning they're using more
than one building or an online school
and or a tutor and and I can remember
one example there's a child taking two
AP classes is in a public high school
two classes at an online school and
tutoring for another school and they
break down about 50 50. about half the
kids are in one provider that looks like
a brick and mortar building in New
Hampshire and about half the kids are
using many providers for one child so
they might look like a you might think
of them as an educated at home child but
they might be in a public school and
online school and a private school and
using a tutor does that help okay great
and I'll get that's the stuff that
you'll get when I give you a an annual
report which I would I wish you would
have already had that information in
front of you
the last several questions we've had are
dealing with it right more off topic
questions but they're off the topic of
this but they are good questions which
the committee wants to you would like to
see yes the administrative cost at 10
yeah that represents right and you know
that was representative Tanner yeah so
if we use less administrative money I
get to give more money to kids so it
would increase the grants and so I
absolutely want to do that yeah so those
are some of the things which we want to
look at in terms of the in the use issue
that uh representative luno just looked
at but let's keep the rest of the
questions here on target please dealing
with this because 500 of the poverty
lineable yes yeah representative
Woodcock was your hand up
yes it was chairman thank you uh thank
you for taking my question and good to
see you again this year uh and I
appreciate the fact that you're willing
to at least present the work that Doe
has yet to present I love talking about
my work on either of these bills
considering the major uh doe bills and
they're not here to speak to the bill
which I find uh said and that that being
said Mike my question is uh in the
earlier bill
um
yeah because you may have the answer the
deal he isn't here uh in the earlier
bill they indicated and the governor's
projected budget he had 30 million
dollars yeah in the accounts
um and the question that was raised was
that in anticipation of this bill being
passed or was that the cover of the
current expenses to this or do you know
that answers I don't know the answer
okay thank you thank you Mr chair you're
welcome further questions representative
pardon me thank you yeah represent
balbooni oh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question
um earlier today earlier in your
testimony you referenced um uh the the
family unit of a single parent with one
child that was successing the program
um I was just wondering you because you
might be brought it as perhaps the spam
the situation being but most beneficial
to that the limit raise here
um can you give an idea of how many uh
family in that unit yes so of the
334 children that applied
there were 90 sorry hold on where's my
eyesight
there were less than ten thousand
so a small group not very many kids yeah
further questions but I do think every
kid matters of course right yeah
represent dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you my
pleasure can you address the the
um idea that the educational trust fund
was meant only for publics I really
can't okay no I know our whole education
spending in the state is three billion I
know this is a really tiny part of it I
know that
um that the money moves from the general
fund that's really all general fund
money that the swept stays in the towns
but beyond that you kind of that that's
kind of the limits of my my knowledge of
the funding mechanism at the state level
thank you I know it's a funding
mechanism yeah further questions
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question my pleasure
so in your example and I'm sure there
are others like this of the student
taking two AP courses and some online
and something else yeah
is there any
money from the EFA
Grant or funding that that student has
going back to the public school for the
services the public schools providing
yes they're building the families for
the classes and courses that they're
taking in most cases some of them are
letting the families do some things like
sports because their local taxpayers so
I've heard both some families are paying
the schools and they're billing them
some schools are allowing families to do
things because they're local taxpayers
when you have the expenses you'll see
some of the public schools and what
they're receiving like for example
there's a student full-time at bath
Village School and there's a student
full time at Souhegan High School and
there's a student full-time at somehegan
Middle School Amherst Middle School is
the name of it at souhegan's the high
school but some families are choosing
other Public Schools full-time and some
of them are choosing classes and courses
and the public schools have signed up as
providers and are billing them
because they wouldn't otherwise right
well they're getting the adequacy
because remember the EFA has the step
down so they still get the adequacy in
the first year and 100 because they're
paid a year in arrears then they get 50
then they get 25 when a kid chooses the
education Freedom account but then we're
also paying them
yeah so they're getting it twice really
follow-up is this fun okay we have fun
now
so
it sounds like it's at the discretion of
the school district so I think they
should build for the funding I think
they should Bill yes no regulation is
that correct it's not required I don't
know I think it should be maybe required
because the dual enrollment law for
homeschoolers really doesn't apply to
these students because remember they're
not homeschoolers anymore there's a
separate part of the the compulsory
attendance law they become an education
Freedom account student
I think the districts locally have the
discretion of whether they want to do it
or not but again now you're in the
public school law realm and I just don't
have enough information to answer the
question but I think the families seem
happy to pay it if the public school is
billing them for a class or course or if
they're choosing an out of District
school then they're billing them the
tuition amount you know like for example
that the tuition at to go to Souhegan
High School was 25 000 and the family
was using the education Freedom account
and a scholarship to pay for it both
and so I think they in most cases will
build the families unless they are
thinking about this perhaps dual
enrollment law but I don't know enough
about it to really the school
administrators know more and they're the
ones that have been telling me what the
families should pay and then giving the
families the documentation right now
we're getting way into the way up sorry
this is fun stuff back here
um I'm gonna allow one more I have
another person who wants to speak here
today too and look at the clock folks
we're going to go right through without
lunch
so I'm wondering how you come up with
income levels whether it's earned income
um because we don't have a that's a
great we don't have an income tax here
so that's the government doesn't take
that yeah so how do you do the same as
the federal uh free reduced lunch it's
household income so it's not only your
W-2 income that you earn it's also if
you have food stamps or you have housing
subsidy or you have child support or you
have social security income so household
income is everyone in the household and
to be honest that's married or not the
way they look at that so we're
collecting all that documentation from a
whole household to come up with this
income and that's the same way that the
federal government says to do the free
and reduced lunch program
thank you
I'm going to close the questions to you
know we're going to close the questions
right now if you have a question to ask
ask it after the we could take one more
yeah no we're not going to go there
thank you very much Kate all right bye
everybody thanks for having me waiting
welcome Maria thank you thank you so
much for having me
my name is Maria Perez I'm the state
representative from District 43 in
Milford I'm here in opposition of this
bill yeah
as someone who went to a private school
growing up my parents never take
advantage of any taxes
my parents never asked for any help
it was their decision to send me a
private school it was their money paying
for a private school
we never take money away from the public
school
for me this has taken money with
students that they really need the
public education
I keep hearing this is gray this is for
underrepresented students
believe me
I'm part of one of those
underrepresented communities
and I don't see these
voucher bills or anything like this is
helping my community
I want to know how many days private
schools or any of this identity that
they say and that they providing
amazing education for students on
they're coming from an underrepresented
communities they care about the students
where English is a second language
I want to know how many others private
schools that have a program that can
help students with different religion
beliefs
I want to know if these private schools
they can tell us
what programs that there are in public
school for kids with a special need
they can provide them I want to know how
they're not really taken in students
because
there are either disabled
are they coming from underrepresented
communities they are afraid to
um
people coming from communities with
violence and it's you know uh
it's under communities
none of these people saying you know
exactly how the money is being used
how many of the students that went and
took the money for the abortion money
the parents decided that private school
wasn't their thing and they sent the
kids back to the public school
so they took the money from the voucher
now the kids going back to the public
school but that founding is not there
for public school in my own district and
offer a public school they have a lot of
projects that they need to be done
but the schools don't have the funding
we have a student that they can even get
lunches
but we keep taking money away from the
public school when the public school
should be funded
we need to remind ourselves that the a
lot of kids don't qualify for going to
these private schools let their parents
who have enough money to send the kids
to private school send them to private
school but do not use my taxpayers money
the people in my community to pay for
your private school because that's what
you want to do and reliably speakers
here I heard them that they they either
represented private schools
or they're represented and someone or
the group that um a second advantage of
this let's be honest
listen to the parents who cannot afford
it to send their kids to private schools
listen to the teachers they have to
spend their own money to buy
and the private and the public school
enough is enough we're giving enough
money away already it's time for us to
give it back to the public school and
stop taking away from the public school
kids dessert
to have public education and teachers
deserve to have what they need to teach
these kids
thank you for your time and I will take
questions thank you for your testimony
are there any questions
yes represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony we've we've just heard
I think strong insinuation that some
programs or some schools that are
involved with education Freedom accounts
maybe discriminating against uh English
as a second language Learners or against
minority students and I'd just like to
ask do you have any do you have any
evidence or data either anecdotal or
data that that would support that with
all my respect that I say I would love
to see information I would love to see a
report
what exactly did they do to really work
for the people on the representative
because I heard them saying that that
this Federal account is to work with the
underrepresented community that's why I
would love to see a report exactly what
are they doing for people for they
underrepresented communities and people
who English or other issues as you know
is secondary necessary I would love to
see that and that's what I'm asking for
thank you
further questions
thank you very much
with that I'm going to close this
hearing and we're going to break for
lunch
and we will pick up the rest of the
docket today when we come back at the
hey I'll tell you one thing Kate is
undermining Frank
and we got you know they should have
been
foreign
thank you very much I do have a pink
card up there on the table somewhere uh
for the record my name is Rick Ladd I
come from Haverhill I Graft in five I'm
here today to introduce 365 relative to
Statewide facility condition assessment
um this bill is one of three which uh
one will be going directly to finance
the other two we're going to have in
committee here the ultimate goal of this
committee we will be looking at the
entire process for school building aid
from the application process and all
procedures associated with it right
through the awarding of Grants so we've
got we have another bill coming at 452
that's not this bill but this is comes
out of the same section of law as all
the others so the intent of this bill
was to then support the the 10-year plan
which we currently have and I'll explain
that in a moment but it's in the same
sectional law as others so this might be
something that we incorporate into the
other Bill too if we're going to do a
healthy good study on school building
Aid this year this may be something
which we merged several bills together
so with it I'll go ahead and start
as it says right there in the paper it
but the purpose ability it's in support
of the 10-year school facilities plan we
uh in last session put forward
legislation where like we have a 10-year
plan for a build uh a school uh highways
and roads and bridges we're looking at
the same issue here associated with our
school facilities
we have a number of buildings which are
needed help and I'll get into the
specifics on that and we'll Biff here
um but going on through that top part
districts are encouraged to submit uh
projected long-range Capital needs to
include the identification School
renovation and construction goals
Associated projected expenditures and
procedures to accomplish stated needs
purpose of the whole thing is so that
the state department or the Department
of Education and the State Board of
Education including in the legislature
which has to appropriate dollars in
support of school building Aid each
biennium and we have the two years which
we support currently about 50 million
dollars of which you heard the other day
over at doe that we're actually funding
half that for new renovation our
renovation and new construction the rest
is going off to pay our debt what we
call the tail
and we're going to have the tail gone in
year 2040s when we finished the last
payment on that 540 million dollars this
state was in debt for back 10 years ago
or actually 12 years ago and and as a
result of that debt we've just come out
of the 10-year moratorium which is
actually just compounded our school
building aid program as far as the
school districts are concerned with
buildings that are just hard to maintain
and keep up there's an underlying
portion at the top of that paper I just
handed out to you
I thought it would be interesting for
you to see how this whole project School
the success of our whole system depends
as much on a thorough reform in the
construction and care of schoolhouses as
upon any other single circumstance
whatever
the commissioner common schools for the
State of New Hampshire and the
presentation to the legislature back in
June 1847 hadn't changed much
I consider school buildings as really a
fourth leg of the stool in terms of our
ensuring that we're providing an
education which is necessary for kids to
meet our kids students to meet the
post-secondary needs or get on the
career pathways
and without good school building school
buildings we're not going to have the
facilities to do some things which we
need to do to stay up where we are with
our Workforce demands
going down and jumping I'll come back to
the school building Aid Authority School
Authority uh in a minute when I explain
what that organization is and what it
does
why is there a need for school building
Aid look at some of the bullets that we
have there evidence 50 of our school
buildings in New Hampshire are over 60
years old
six percent were built prior to 1900.
26 percent built prior to 1950.
seven schools are over 68 years old have
not had a major renovation more than 50
years a major renovation
so we're talking about in some law
schools which they may have corrected
with Esser monies HVAC you've been in
schools where you hear the radiators
they're banging and clunking away as
they're exchanging air going outside and
we have to change the filters in those
because they're all independent of and
run alone and teachers oftentimes who
put I did as a teacher kids clothes were
wet after recess you put them in all
your smelling in the classroom is
mittens and gloves and hats and coats
that are wet
uh going on down here 196 schools 60
originally built 50 plus years ago
15 percent of schools are using portable
classrooms we have several of those
which we're using up in Haverhill where
I am right now where we have preschool
program in and a library in it and so we
have portable classrooms start and
they're not the most ideal situation for
instruction
uh numerous HVAC systems when this was
compiled a couple years back perhaps
some of that has been changed now with
the Esser money but as rated by
administrators when they look into
systems at best they were Fair most were
poor and many were in need of
replacement
we've gone through as I said before a
10-year uh building Aid moratorium
moratorium new construction Revolution
projects funds minimal due to State debt
tail okay so in order to address these
issues
we came out of the moratorium several
years back and we were able with 18
million dollars to fund three small
projects
didn't go very far
did help Romney it did help behavioral
and several others but that was about
the extent of it
um education learning associated with
school facilities why are school
facilities important let's look at it
right students in poor buildings needing
significant Renovations or upgrades form
less well than students in functional
buildings
I think you could identify that
represent cascadden with the elementary
school you had up there in Maryland
Research indicates a student in poor
building score five to ten percentile
points below students in functional
facilities there is a correlation there
is a relationship where if you don't
have a chemistry lab if you don't have
proper facilities for special education
if you don't have the conference room
space you can go on with all this list
if the classrooms are old and don't have
the needs the technology within you are
not going to be able to compete against
some of the newer schools which have all
that inclusive and and modern media
centers Etc
Research indicates that students as that
student in poor buildings score five ten
percentile points below students and
functional facilities
difference in achievement scores can be
as high as 17 percentile points
older buildings here are some of the
concerns we're dealing with control a
thermal environment control the
environment it's you can go into places
you find a steaming hot in one room you
go next door it's like Thule Greenland
and coal acceptable lighting we're
trying to teach we should be trying to
teach manuscript at least in schools and
you go in an Elementary classroom and
how many times is a kid seeing their
shadow on the paper
um it's it's inappropriate
um it's very difficult for many many
students
and what we're trying to do is counter
that with the type of lighting we put in
but if you mix and Max lighting you can
have worse conditions as a study in
Vermont and that it is just 10 years ago
then by just leaving them alone
acoustical control
how many times can hear what's going on
in the classroom right beside you
or how can you hear you hear the band
practicing in what was once and then in
a classroom and is bouncing off through
the school
um functional equipment in the rooms
themselves
uh lab space appropriate space nurses
science cafeteria storage gym conference
room especially I was just listening a
couple last night I could go on and that
list could be a running list of
functional spaces necessary
um to compound the issue most of the
older schools and those in poor
conditions are located in areas of
Greater poverty
other words we've had some schools that
built during the moratorium period but
they came from communities which could
have they could fund their own bonds
they could do it the poor communities
couldn't do it so you're left with these
buildings
the reason why Romney got their uh
upgrade for elementary school here two
years ago you couldn't even get in the
building if you're in a wheelchair you
had to go up four steps to get into the
building it was built up higher you
couldn't access the second floor of the
snow elevator so they had ensure all the
Middle School classes were down lower
and where the kids were rotating between
classrooms and I don't know how John Ann
did it but she's a wonderful principal
and she managed it but they did get that
Grant
um
there's a strong link between school
building Aid and the delivery of an
adequate education there is there's a
link we've also know we've seen that in
uh representative Myler saw that when he
chaired the commission for the task
force for funding and I did a a research
paper on that as well and we do know
that if you look at the 13 cities in
this state two are basically co-step
proficient the others are not and so
this and they are communities which
cannot raise some of that dollars
Manchester being one
uh so there's a number of schools which
don't have the ability to raise the
dollars necessary and and the fiscal
capacity to variate is has not done what
it should do and there is a that
contributes to our achievement in
schools
aspects of the current building
application and procedures needed and
that need consideration now we're
getting down this 10-year plan why do we
have a 10-year plan or need a 10-year
plan
um I don't have the numbers in front of
me but we looked the other day over at
uh doe and or right here with Amy Clark
who gave us a presentation on those 17
schools that have applied for building a
construction
and we've received over 500 some odd
million dollars in requests the state
share 30 to 60 percent would be
somewhere around 200 plus thousand two
hundred million dollars
um so
um there's an order which we have to do
when when we get those rank order sheets
to the State Board of Education there's
a process which we've gone through as a
state to determine which ones have the
highest need
and they did that evidently with the
schools which are receiving it are
proposed to receive it in this biennium
Rochester then came Colebrook and then
came Monadnock elementary schools but
below that you see Concord coming on
with a project of 70 million dollars
worth
now if we're funding schools at 50
million bucks we're not ever going to
get near that need to help conquered out
or some of these other high schools
which are now going well over three
digits in terms of millions of dollars
so we we developed and we're trying to
get a handle on this with a 10-year plan
which we had several years ago we're
trying to get a better handle so we can
prioritize and plan where we're going
the idea back then I believe the bill
was if I'm correct it was HP 214 I
believe at that point in time we're
trying to develop a process in which we
could send Engineers policy people
Architects out on teams to inspect all
our facilities and so we would be
inspecting all these facilities
based upon the same criteria these
engineers and policy people would be
doing it cleared out this how this body
unanimously
it got to house finance and it went
downhill fast
the reason why is that we were looking
at how we were going to fund that and
working with doe we determined it was
going to cost approximately 3.3 million
dollars for these teams to go out and
give us this information back
we were going to take approximately 1.3
million of that from the public school
infrastructure fund which was carry over
its uh monies which we don't lose uh so
we would have had that and we had
appropriated another two million dollars
which we were going to use for electric
buses and which we have not used for
that we were going to use it for this
team and we would have gone out and done
that uh however that two million dollars
now and not 1.3 have been used for
security in our schools which is equally
as important a concern
with the public school safety uh
Commission
so what we want to do is we want to try
and get from districts report so what
are going to be your needs as we do with
highways and bridges and Roads
and have a 10-year plan so we can better
understand what's out there and in
conjunction with our process for
receiving applications and I wrote a few
bullets last night late probably around
11 30. so I probably missed something
here aspects of current building
application procedures needing
consideration department and legislative
planning prioritization anticipated
Capital appropriation sources of revenue
relative School building Aid
those are things which we have to tackle
we will with the bill which we kind of
coming in but one of the things we want
to look at and we've heard it spoken to
a little bit when we talk about another
topic this morning where does the money
for school building Aid come from
can we possibly have some of that
allocated out of the education trust
fund can we set up another way of
ensuring that the money is going to be
there so that when we can have these
10-year plans we can actually have money
to support where we're going
um application timelines if you are a
superintendent of schools or School
Board looking at building you know it's
a real long process to try to even think
you're going to get building Aid in the
state and if you're a poor District like
the one I come from and I would say
probably also for the Berlin School
District you may get you may get 60
percent from the state but at least a
huge chunk for a district that's a a
poor town
so the timeline first thing that
department education is going to ask of
us to do is submit a letter of intent
your letter of intent has to be and when
has to be in there before July 1 but
between July 1 and January 15th we have
to take all the applications that have
come forward and by January 15th come
out and have this prioritized by this
state uh Board of Education
that's virtually very difficult almost
impossible to do accurately seeing that
the process starts the building
applications are received by Amy Clark
over doe she looks them over the
department looks them over
they put them in a rank order they send
that on the school building authority
now the school building authority when
that was established back in
1997 I believe excuse me 1961
here's what it was set up for by the um
Committee on Public Schools structure uh
districts and super supervisory unions
back in 1691. it's recommended a state
school building of Aid Authority be
established to provide financial
assistance
standard plans and insurance for schools
and school districts of New Hampshire
looking at bonding capacity of these
districts looking the bonding capacity
of the the state in terms of supporting
these Aid grants
so we do send right now as a check the
criteria based on criteria which we've
gone through and rated all the
applications on I won't go in that
criteria the length of the list is very
long everything from demographics to
size of class and special services all
that's incorporated into this
and that is submitted on to the school
building authority they check it out to
see if it gels with you know their
perspective perception of this rank
order gels with that came from Doe
uh there
being asked to do a job
which actually that group was never set
up to do
you can see that on the back side there
who is a member of that particular group
the state treasurer Commission of
Education the State Fire Marshal and
three others appointed by the governor
one with education background one with
Finance background one with as a
construction or engineer
they look at this process and within a
period of several weeks have to come out
with a conclusion the rancor looks good
that you can't do it they can't get site
visitations so what we're gonna have to
do with our timeline we're gonna have to
back that off at least by I would say at
least by another six months out in
probably farther than that with the
letter intent coming in and then getting
into the other aspects of what an
applicant application entails
and that is incumbent upon the school
district to start doing that they have
to go out and get the schematic plans
done and all that other done and hire an
architect hire an engineer come in and
give them a rough idea what they're
going to have but the other big issue is
so we come out in January 15th with hear
so much money you're going to receive
School District
now you have how much time before you
can get that as a warrant article
maybe a week or two
because you've got to get it published
and then you're in trouble so here we
are the process is is too condensed we
need to strengthen that out we gotta
talk about the capital a 10-year plan we
gotta talk about all this so my
suggestion is right now that we look at
this bill as a part of the subsequent
Bill 452 which will be coming at us and
we take and look at all our
processes and procedures necessary from
get to go get to the end of the process
here so we can look at where these
revenues are coming from and how we're
going to receive applications a timeline
and and assist these districts in trying
to you know remediate this issue which
they have out there we have too many old
buildings which are constricting what
we're able to do in education yes we are
a state that has many rural areas and
they have no options to you know they
have to provide these Services even at a
cost which they're not provided the
money to do in order to be provide equal
Services they have to have AP courses
too
and they have to have the staff to do it
so a lot of things we've got to look at
I'll close my I don't want to ramble on
here too much more this is a huge topic
it's one which I'd really appreciated as
the school administrator for years I
went through the building process in
Alaska and I can remember building the
last building we did our high school
back then about 20 years ago was over 90
million dollars
and um I compare where I was there to
what I see here in this state
they had an Olympic-sized swimming pool
in it they had a theater with us as
could fit 600 people with an orchestra
pit in the building they had a science
wing math Wings vocational education in
the school unbelievable they had a
several football fields soccer fields
um all of it
and and here I haven't seen it of course
that's not part of school building Aid
the all the Athletics is not you know
that representative Woodcock but the
academic stuff is so we got to make sure
we're hitting that properly thank you
very much
uh thank you a question of
Representative miler
thank you Mr chair so if I understand
the intent of this bill
is to identify as to provide these
10-year plans that would give us some
idea of the status of buildings
so that it might then provide some
impetus for additional state aid funding
that's part of it yes just so also we
know for example you'll see a second
sheet there that comes from the state of
Idaho is that attached to your sheet
there
they're having a similar problem out
there they were getting these reports
while we had these needs in our schools
and the people which are completing
those reports happen to be the custodian
in the building or somebody that didn't
have that expertise to know what was
behind that wall whether it's asbestos
behind the wall just like we're finding
over in Pleasant Street where doe is
supposed to be
so what they're getting in from the
schools was not necessarily enough to
build these and prioritize the lists
which we need and I'm concerned that we
need to have the capital Improvement
information
ahead of time so we can better plan and
know these revenues are coming from and
so we can't facilitate the needs of the
districts
I hope that answers a little bit about
it but that's part part of the issue
part of the issue we just gotta need
what's know what's out there
and hopefully we can get that in for the
capital Improvement program they do it
with roads and highways and bridges
uh thank you
um representative cascadden
thank you acting chair
um my question is who who is building a
no what entities
can apply for building Aid
now who who is the building aid for
is for our Public Schools thank you and
but there you'll also see in one part of
the statue where it says a charter
school can receive 30 however that's why
we have a bill coming up for
recodification because in another place
you go into finance and it says the
opposite okay so what we're seeing is
that one section law says you can one
say the law says you can't what do you
follow right and this is the confusion
we have this is why I believe US
Representative Hill to put that bill in
for re-codification that's a result of
folks attorneys over there and
legislative Services saying it's time to
really get this thing fixed and just to
re-codify education
laws I would say it's going to take to
do it properly a couple years
representative Tanner
uh thank you and thank you for
approaching this subject that's uh
very testy in the local areas
um I'm just wondering I know the the
bill is uh strongly urge rather than
require or shall or would
um
how much is this going to cost local
districts money or do you think this is
this is what they probably are going
through
on a regular basis anyway with their own
needs we see already in place the
10-year plan that's in statute the way
the
um the state is developing that 10-year
plan is we have a department of one over
there at doe right now
that's responsibility for other tasks
other than School building Aid and they
are making the decision they're
prioritizing over internally
uh we we have had to build 214 where we
recognize the encourage recommend first
do it we're going to do it we tried the
do it side and we weren't provided the
funding the 3.3 million dollars which we
needed to do it would professional
people going out and doing site
visitations so now it we know that there
are a number of districts which are in
the process of going after building Aid
right now that have hired architects
and that's an expensive proposition my
District's doing that right now and yet
you don't see them even listed on that
list of 17. so some have this
information it's not a mandatory thing
they do this but I would think down the
roadways when we have this list properly
developed that will be the list that we
start looking at in terms of rank
ordering how we're going to facilitate
our Revenue such we have in expending
them out to help building Aid we've got
to have a better plan and place than we
do now I recognize that in this there's
things that have to be tweaked that's
why I say we need to hold on to this one
until we do 452 and do them both
simultaneously and answer these
questions is a good question
representative Tanner and we're we're
going to have to really address this one
we tried last year we were unsuccessful
thank you representative Woodcock did
you have a question
thank you chairman thank you
good afternoon
um
similar to uh Tan's question I was
looking at a similar thing and on the
line in your uh revision or Edition uh
in 12 and 15 Rick you use the word a
recommended wants and encourage once I
wonder why if it's going to be required
in the 10-year plan why wasn't that more
strong as representative sort of
indicated that shall or must
I'm all for it but you know that's why
we need to work on all this uh
recommended is you're we're trying to
stay away from that unfunded mandate
okay okay and that's the Crux of it
before represent yes Mr chairman thank
you um
I don't have a good handle on this whole
piece but a school uh payroll for
instance so Conway that is not he's not
looking at we will be on the way on the
10-year plan we or I think copacetic and
emergency hits and we lose a whole
building the whole roof the everything
falls in how how does that uh then uh
get approached there there is money for
emergency projects in the state so if
the roof or the Kenneth Middle School
Falls in which you know your new high
school is a pretty decent building
because I think it is the Beats
Woodsville well knew it was a decade
over go ahead oh a decade okay let's
compare ages here uh yeah there you go
yeah
okay but there isn't right so that
doesn't impact this
there is for example we had an issue in
Haverhill Middle School which is a
relatively new building it was built in
the 1990s okay
and they had I couldn't believe what I
saw
the art room was downstairs this
two-story
our room is downstairs and then they
vented the Kiln which is in the art room
up the side of the building and into the
Attic
not more in about 20 years later the
whole roof was rotten
and everything holding the roof up is
ready to go
and so we had to spend one year with our
students in the National Guard Armory
while we used emergency money coming
from the state to help us fix that now
that is as you may recall on school
building Aid now
you have to have for projects of a
certain size a clerk of the works that's
bonded and knowledgeable as like an
engineer before the clerk of the works
could have been your head custodian
and you know change orders would come in
from the contractors and things got
approved just like that and the price of
that building doubled immediately so we
we're trying to get a grip on where
we're going with this thank you thank
you for the question
any further questions from the
committee see none thank you thank you
um Mr Kirk do we have any further cards
for this bill
no
okay
and no one else testify evidently so I
will close the hearing on House Bill 365
and
um in a moment we will take up house
foreign
okay we're ready to go ahead with uh
this bill we're now about 35 minutes
late
um relative to non-academic surveys
administered by a public school or a
Charter Public School to its students
this is HB 380 has a financial note
after it so it is an early Bill
welcome representative Horrigan thank
you
foreign
from Stratford County District 10 which
is a town of Durham
um
I did I've written testimonies the same
as testimony I submitted through the web
portal but uh
I figured I had to print up at least one
hard copy for myself so I know what I
said and also I haven't quite figured
out exactly where it is these things go
or how we access them but it's it's a
new system so I'm it's a
The Spill probably looks very familiar
to a lot of us and we had a very
identical Bill pretty much except for
the uh I think the effective date maybe
the only thing that we changed in 2020
right before the covid-19 emergency
which is the subject of the other Bill
is doing up in labor Earth but it worked
out pretty good uh labor was right on
time and you're a few minutes late and
then my own committee Judiciary is way
late so it's working out pretty good for
me
and this table the Senate during the
emergency and then that was similar to
another bill SB 196 which passed into
2019 but it was one of medievals vetoed
by governor sununu in 2019.
so um and also mentioned in addition to
being a rep from Durham I'm also a
member of the vital uh
the vital records privacy board and I
see the chair of that board is uh
attending the hearing whether she's
planning to speak or not I'm not sure
but I hope I hope she does so I'm sure
her comments will be much more valuable
than mine it's
very difficult virtually impossible to
schools to participate meaningfully
under surveys about drug use social
behavior public health and other
sensitive personal topics with the
exception of one survey
which I believe it's every two years
like maybe it's misinformed but it's the
cdc's youth-rich behavior survey and the
reason they had a carve out for that one
was because
we would have watched I think tens of
millions maybe a huge sum of money would
have been lost if we didn't participate
in that one so that was uh that's why
that's why there's a carve out of the
current law which by the way dates back
a little bit before 2019.
um
and uh a governor said when he vetoed
the bill of 2018 to decrease his
personal parental involvement but that's
not true I think these surveys increased
parental involvement um
at the time of the minister the surveys
he raised important questions to
students wines and I found uh students
to take these questionnaires and just
like the standardized tests they tend to
take them pretty seriously this raises
questions what they can to do discuss at
home with their parents and also when we
analyze it we learn more about these
issues
and I'm also a lot of this data
qualifies us for federal and other
funding
so this would be back actually should be
back to the way the bills 2015 is when
this whole RSA was first put in the
books and we would schools would once
again be able to participate in
non-academic surveys and parents would
be able to
the parents would have to opt out of
each survey if they don't want their
children to participate right now they
have to opt into every survey which
greatly reduces the participation and
creates a lot of work for the schools
and the parents so the default is going
to be for them to be allowed to
participate
and you know there's a wealthy useful
information surveys in many cases those
surveys are prerequisite for Grants and
or eligibility participated programs and
uh
got a paragraph here about the
legislative history I'll skip over that
um
yeah so the the as I said the why the
reason that one survey was uh included
just because the cost was
the cost of and there are many members
of the legislature who want to opt out
of that one too but the cost would have
been would have lasted a huge hole in
the uh in the uh in education funding so
um and we've lost millions of dollars
anyway just from uh the current law so
and finally I'll say uh finally I'll say
and certainly uh I've learned a little
bit more about this from the vital
records privacy board even though that's
not really educational surveys per se
they're undertaken with very stringent
requirements so the federal government
has strict laws that govern all data
collection by federally funded programs
including those funded by what they call
pass-through dollars
and there's additional protections for
vulnerable subpopulations which includes
uh children under 18. so
especially the area of Public Health
without the data from these uh
scientific surveys we can't measure the
effective Public Health interactions we
can't we don't and we don't have a good
idea of how they affect our educational
system or our children and this is
especially true of the substance abuse
crisis but it applies a lot of other
issues too so that I would
basically uh you know it took a few I
think we uh got the law pretty much
right in 2015 there's a few changes from
what the original Law in 2015 and so I I
urge you to uh
um sorry I urge you to finally fix this
problem and allow our schools to
participate in these surveys so I'd be
happy to take any questions if you'd
like foreign
thank you very much any questions
representative cordelli uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you uh representative
Horrigan for uh coming back again this
afternoon
um uh I was interested in in your
written testimony
um and what you mentioned in terms of
the uh strict laws of the federal
government related to data collection
programs uh such as with surveys and
um one of the reasons the opt-in was put
into law as I recall
was a federal provision called the
protection of pupil Rights Amendment
which specifies that
any survey collecting
data as you'll see in lines 21 22 in in
the bill
um it's in current statute that is
gathered via a federal funding must have
written parental consult and consent
um
and so as I recall the testimony when
the opt-in provision was put into place
it was to mirror federal law and the
strict laws that you mentioned in your
testimony
um why is it that you think at this
point the federal requirements should be
eliminated from our provision for
non-academic surveys well I can't really
speak to whether or not that
summary what the law is and certainly um
I mean certainly we would want parents
to like uh
part of the paperwork at the beginning
of the semester would be this would be
to have something you know opting into
any future surveys without uh without uh
specifically you know without
specifically having to go through the
paperwork every time to opt in so like
uh and of course this is uh enabling
legislation so I'm sure the school
districts can adopt a more restriction
policy if they feel that's in their
interests and then there's also there's
some surveys
that are not directly funded with
federal dollars like in that University
of New Hampshire Ministries a lot of
administrative surveys to a about
various topics to the students so that's
um yes in terms of the federal law in
terms of federal law I can't
I'm not prepared to say whether or not
your summary what it says is correct or
not so
I'd be glad to give you a copy I'll
leave that for the committee committee
may want to like dig into that support
be glad to give the community a copy
sure but my follow-up question is
um in terms of a blanket acceptance or
provision
um for uh consent at the beginning of
the school year for any non-academic
survey
um I would think was in conflict with um
beginning parts of the statute that
requires individual notification and I
believe making available copies of the
survey to the parent before their
written consent so how would you see
that additional parts of this
legislation might need to be amended in
order to provide a blanket beginning of
the year consent
yeah I
certainly uh I was envisioning a blanket
beginning with your consent and if
that's
if what's what's in this bill isn't
sufficient to do to allow for that then
obviously that's
that's once again that's something else
the committee can look into during the
executive session and then the retained
Brew process if that's what they want
but I do I do know that I've heard a lot
of concern from the research Community
about the current law that it's uh it
makes it very difficult to get
meaningful data out of these
non-academic surveys
thank you
I have one question and then I'll open
it up to the rest of the committee uh on
line 12 and 13
you inserted language where it says
um beyond the uh the survey developed by
the Centers for Disease Control and
prevention and you say and surveys
related to other prevention programs so
this is appears to me
is it providing that uh department on
the federal level the ability to as you
say
obtain research
uh
without
having to go through all the it just as
freely as they can with the Center for
Disease Control and prevention
and what are these other surveys
Chicago's basically
well what I had what I envisioned and um
it's been envisioned the previous
version of the pillow says if if there's
something in addition to the very
specific ybrs which is a lot yeah
long-running survey if I remember
correctly it's administered just once
every two years but the CDC decides to
expand that program then
New Hampshire would be able to
participate and obviously so obviously
the certainly you can't even have these
surveys unless you know the department
the state so often very education I need
just one clarification here as what you
just mentioned
I understand the yrbs yeah we've been
doing that for years yeah now if that's
amended or if it's the same survey I
it's it's still allowable according to
language previously had but it appears
that you're extending it beyond that to
other surveys or other forms of
gathering research by the federal
government is that where you're going I
guess that uh
I mean I guess I would say I guess I
would probably say I would say probably
yes obviously the CDC would have to like
establish the program it would have to
pass you know mustard with the federal
you know the federal agency you know the
federal bodies report to and then the
state would have to approve our
participation the survey and then I
suppose the school districts have their
say on the two before the and of course
the parents will be notified about that
just as they hear about the ybrs so they
would know about that so that's um I I
don't Envision any major changes in that
for the next few next few years but just
in case
just in case they change the name of the
ybrs or expand or come up with a similar
surveys we'd like to be able to
participate in them are there other
questions from the committee yes
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um so to clarify
um
you agree that this this bill has the
effect of uh creating rather than an opt
in system parents would have to opt out
on an individual basis for for these
surveys
um yes exactly yes uh follow up to that
um
I am aware of some more modern education
models such as under the rubric of SEL
where information that would be listed
under this previous prohibition is asked
on a regular basis as a part of the
program to do essentially data mining to
do what they call generative themes
learning this could be incorporated into
regular models so is it possible that
with this requirement to both notify
parents and also to opt out on an
individual basis that parents could
actually wind up meaning to be informed
of and opting out of perhaps even
multiple uh surveys on a daily basis
hello
I I I'm not familiar with the details
what was that model of Education I
didn't catch the name of it uh SEO of
social emotional learning okay that's uh
well I'm not I'm not on the humidity so
I'm not
at the processor I have to admit that's
the first time I've heard of that
particular model of learning but I think
I understand uh
what it said so that's you know I mean
if that's the integral part of the
program then um
presumably obviously the family has to
opt into the whole program before the
kid can be in it unless you know so
um
yeah I guess I mean he even is now on
the other the anchorsy kids sort of had
the power to opt out they can refuse to
participate in things although that's
pretty difficult for a school child to
do so that's um I don't know how that's
different than the way these issues are
dealt with and uh and other educational
models so that's not the best answer I
have thanks thank you
yes represent McDonald and then
represent Miler thank you Mr chair
thanks for the testimony is there an
ability for a parent to Simply opt out
of all surveys for an academic year as
opposed to as representative Belcher
noted maybe multiple in one day or this
could come to be quite a task for the
parents so again are they able to just
opt out of all surveys for their
children
um that would
I would
I mean I think that would probably be
like that'd probably be an appropriate
the school district could make a
procedure for that so I'm just trying to
change this so the
um the technology for them to opt-in
they certainly actually I guess the
school district could make these surveys
opt out which may create difficulty for
them in terms of funding and other other
things but school districts are still
free to go back to the opt-out model and
certainly
I mean I suppose a parent probably could
just say they want to opt out of every
non-academic survey even if it's even if
we're going to the opt-in model that I'm
envisioning with the bill so
thank you representative thank you Mr
chair before I ask my question
um for the committee's information this
is this bill has had a long history and
we have we've worked on this for a
number of years and what we found in the
past is that there were
in some school districts there was
inappropriate
age inappropriate
surveys that were being given by
independent teachers and it caused all
kinds of problems
and so as a compromise to all that we
basically came up with the issue of the
yrbs the the youth risk behavior survey
which is an annual thing that gives a
lot of information to school districts
about youth Behavior Uh which they then
can develop programs to address those
issues and so that's why we kind of zero
it all down to the yrbs and I think so
my question yeah representative is that
what I hear you saying here is that
you'd like to expand the option uh for
as you say here uh other related surveys
out of the federal government that might
deal with youth Behavior so that's
that's one expansion and then the other
is basically moving back to an opt out
if parent parental opt out and the
reason why that's has been controversial
here is that in order to get
um the appropriate data to have the a
universe of those participating that
it's that's significant enough that the
data is reliable and by having an opt-in
program uh we in fact I think we likened
it to sending a um a survey home with
kids for a field trip and it doesn't
come back and so how do you get that
data then how do you get that
information from parents so the opt out
provides an opportunity for parents to
be notified a of the survey is being
conducted for them to say okay or if I
don't want that you can I don't want my
child to take that which is perfectly
fine so I think you're trying to move
back to what we had before and then add
potential others is that correct yes
that's correct that's what I think Kim
okay thank you very much I will say
Obviously when I was a kid it was back
in the 70s I think there probably heard
some the surveys Relentless regulated
and probably I did answer some things
that may be weren't appropriate for my
age level but I think yeah
I would agree I would I would pay you I
think you summarized my uh my thinking
uh much better than I could have so
that's an accurate summary so are there
further questions from the committee
foreign
hi okay thank you I appreciate the
opportunity to be here my name is Betsy
Harrington and I'm from daring New
Hampshire
I'd like to tell you my real life
experience with the cdc's youth risk
survey which is given to my kids yearly
it was just given to students at SAU 34
last week on January 12th Thursday
I read the survey and opted my kids out
because I already knew the questions
were Way Beyond their personal
boundaries I learned of the survey last
year
my kids came home on Thursday to tell me
that the survey was given and that the
other kids were really upset my son's
girlfriend who was a freshman told me
that she sat with her friends at lunch
afterwards and talked about it
I asked if anyone was traumatized or
triggered by the survey and she quickly
gave me an emphatic yes I acknowledged
that the survey had questions that were
supposed to be kept private and that she
didn't have to answer she said she felt
really pressured and uncomfortable and
she just got through it I'd like you you
to hear some of this year's questions
it's not what most parents think
during the last 12 months how many times
did someone do sexual things to you that
you did not want to do
during the last 12 months did you make a
plan on how you would attempt suicide
how many times did you attempt did you
get hurt how much spice fake weed K2 or
black mamba have you used my kids have
never heard of these drugs but here's
their introduction
how many sexual partners have you ever
had how old were you when you had in
your course do you exchange things for
sex how much do you drug do you drive in
drug do others drive under the influence
with you in the car
these are questions that should never be
asked of a child it's triggering
boundary breaking and just not for kids
not no follow-up is given to these kids
they're left to die a little bit each
inside they deserve help after being
asked if they were raped or abused
instead they walk away lost with no
support
you can ask an 18 year old these
questions not a child the stated can be
gathered from young adults children
don't need to be subjected to this abuse
from the CDC to collect data I reject
this survey and any other non-academic
survey given to my child during school
hours surveys should never be given
without parental consent imagine parents
who find out after the fact like my
son's girlfriend because they hadn't
read it ahead of time imagine finding
out that your 14 year old was asked
about her sexual and criminal habits
that's getting into abuse territory and
I think that's not okay these surveys
are unwanted by parents and they're
grossly inappropriate for children stop
them and always get permission first if
they are given I can't believe I really
need to say this out loud it seems
logical protect kids from unwanted
surveys without parents knowledge the
year yearly CDC grooming of our kids is
not welcome to New Hampshire parents and
we want permission given first for
anything non-academic
thank you very much are there any
questions
from the committee
does the Department of Health and Human
Services have anything for us on this
one
uh do we have any questions of the
department
you know the CDs you know the uh youth
risk behavior survey
oh we got two of you
welcome good morning representative Vlad
my name is Abby Rogers I'm the
legislative liaison for the division of
Public Health Services and we're here to
provide some information today related
good afternoon my name is
bureau chief of Public Health statistic
informatics in the division of Public
Health Services okay good we too on
that
are there any questions yes represent
Damon
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
it's two parts so the first part is if
you could just explain a little bit more
about the purpose of the use words youth
risk behavior survey maybe I should use
the acronym thank you yes thank you so
yrbs they use the risk behavior survey
New Hampshire adminsterity yrbs since
1993 itas uh administered in odd year
and every other year to the school
public school currently in New Hampshire
is public high schools for grade 9 to
12. the yrbs survey um you know it is a
collaboration between the Department of
Health and Human Services and the
Department of Education and the web yes
is also supported by many partners
across the states who work to achieve
positive outcomes both now and in the
future to for all the use in New I'm
sure so in terms of the process we
collaborate with the internal program
areas in the department as well as the
Department of Education and also the
community organizations not only on the
questionnaire selections but also on the
service and also the program
prevention part
for the
process to only Minister yrbs we first
definitely has identify the
questionnaires and once the
questionnaires is finalized the
department will post the questionnaires
on our website
provide you any school unless on their
first date
and we were recruit the the high schools
through the school district to
um you know encourage them to
participate in yrbs and the school
district and also the school boards has
totally uh control on whether the
schools would like to participate yrbs
or not and whether they would like to
adapt it opt out or obtain approach So
currently in New Hampshire
um for the current statute 186 1190
for yrbs is an exception for opt-in so
whether BS currently is opted out
approach but the school district can
choose if they would like to use opt-in
approach I can provide some information
in the past years since I
started this position there was no
school uh decided to use updating but
provide you like 2000 19 or as far as I
know there was one school they decided
to use up in approach but the next time
when they uh Mr yabs they choose back to
opt out because they didn't get a really
good response rate in order to get their
school data or provide the data to us
and in terms of the confidentiality and
private privacy yrbs
um the process is designed to protect
students privacy by allowing only
Anonymous
participation so no names no date of
birth no social security numbers or
student IDs or other identifiers
identifier excuse me are collected or
required or provided through the survey
the department provides trainings to the
school coordinators and administrators
and also requires classroom teachers who
early Mr yfs to follow Specific
Instructions including you know in the
classroom setting you need to ensure
that no students can pick each other's
screen over the paper and we also
encourage a student to cover their own
desk so that nobody can pick and
teachers is not allowed teachers are not
allowed to walk around you know and they
they are not allowed to look at the
um the survey answer sheet after
students complete if they choose the
paper format so starting 2021 we provide
two format one is the traditional paper
format with the printout questionnaires
and also answer sheets to the schools we
also provide a Web format survey to
allow a student to complete the survey
through the web form met so those are
the two formats that we currently
provide to the school district for them
to you know choose which one would be
best for their webs and I think that's
all I have before the process oh yes
sorry about that thank you I just want
to emphasize that the web yes um it is a
tool that can Catalyst for Community
engagement and positive change this is
the only data set to understand the
youth health and behavior risk factors
for a long run the yrps data is valid
and reliable and that reflects to use
perceptions behavior and experience and
helps schools and communities determine
the previous of health behavior and
assess whether the behavior increase
decrease or keep the same level over
time
so these Trends lines allow schools and
communities to determine if intervention
or prevention strategies are effective
it also enables State and school
districts and communities to assess to
access excuse me federal grants to
assist local schools and communities in
developing Health enhancing policies and
programs for youth so that's what I have
today I don't know I'm happy if I thank
you we just we are not taking a position
on this bill but we wanted to come and
be a resource to the committee and
provide some information I know you have
some new members and I hope that was
helpful also um any questions we'd be
happy to thank you very much there's a
long history of this bill
are this topic uh one question I have
just can you reach I thought the yrbs
was given that one grade level within
the high schools and now 9 through 12
you're ministering each to all those
grades
that is correct so why IBS is
Administrative for old public high
schools in New Hampshire through grade
9-12 that's correct
so all enrolled students in that high
school will receive that
assessment they have the opportunity to
participate in the survey okay yes thank
you questions representative
thank you for taking my question
um
money was alluded to earlier and doing
opt
in
there was I guess
threat of money being taken away by the
federal government and so my question is
where the schools are each individually
allowed to choose opt-in or opt out and
where that school did for one year
choose opt-in my question is if an
individual school as opposed to the
state
chooses opt in
do they have Federal funding taken away
well to participating why ABS is totally
voluntary and some states provide
incentives for schools to participate in
I'm not aware of any grant funding to be
taken from the school level but back to
yrbs if the school choose to opt in then
we would take Aberdeen and there's no
funding will be taken from the
Department thank you
representative uh cardelli and then
representative Damon uh thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you both for uh being
here
um and you were correct in your
observation with a lot of new members
um
first question um I guess would be um I
I think you heard the previous testimony
um that uh the uh lady mentioned some of
the questions
um on this year's uh survey that um she
had thought were um possibly an
intrusive intrusive or inappropriate for
uh her child and I was wondering if um
you had any thoughts on maybe any of
those questions you had you had heard
um as to the regard to their usefulness
and and some follow-up to the survey and
whether they might be appropriate for
certain age levels or not
yes thank you for the question and this
is very important so some questions in
the yrbs survey
um may be consider as a sensitive uh
questions to the students at that age
however asking the question in a very
direct way uh is what um you know
for the long run CDC had yrbs since 1991
and so the questions are kind of
have have a kind of like a scientific
validation to ask that way to the
students so some questions like drug use
or attempted suicide tobacco use or
alcohol use
weapon carrying may come may be
considered as very sensitive to the
students that that party it is accurate
therefore in our training to the schools
and school coordinator and
administrators would be mentioned about
that part that the schools may want to
consult the students or students feels
uncomfortable before after the the
survey school we encourage the school to
reach out to students and have some
consultation to the student for them to
be able to talk about their feelings the
other part that I want to mention is
students has students have the option to
you know to choose that they don't want
to participate the survey even
on the survey date or any time during
the survey if they don't want to answer
the question they can skip the question
and go to the next uh or they can you
know decide that they don't want to
participate the survey then then they
don't need to answer any questions so
there's no penalty or there's no
um performance or would impact if they
don't answer the question or if they
don't participate this way during the
survey
follow-up question yes thank you I'm
glad to hear that um you uh tell the
schools that
they might follow up with students on
some of these questions such as suicide
because I remember when we did the uh
Suicide Hotline uh number being put on
the ID cards we had discussion whether
that was going to put suicide in the
child's mind possibly so and I see that
could happen with this so I'm glad to
hear that you offer that advice but also
on the advice side I was wondering if
your department or maybe the Department
of Education had issued any advisories
to local schools that they could change
from opt out to opt in in relation to
um
you want to take the up top sure thank
you for the question
um I I'm not sure I I don't have the
answers to whether the schools have
given that that
um been guidance by the Department of
Education on whether the about the
opt-in and opt out of individual schools
I I would remind the committee that
um the it is uh the school's
responsibility per law to post the the
survey online for parents to um have
access to that prior to the application
of the survey so those questions are
there and parents can review them and
decide whether they feel comfortable
having their child participate in or not
I mean that's already in statute that
that be done by the schools
think thank you and I'm sorry I just
want to follow up on that the department
also provide opt out uh template and we
posted the template on our website as
well for
um parents who if they do not receive
directly from the schools they are able
to print it out and sign the opt-out
form and and hand it back to the schools
and in terms of up in we provide the
operating template per request so so far
no schools are requesting update but
again this will be the school district
and School Board decision if they would
like to take up in or up and down option
from the Department standpoint we do
encourage uh the the school district and
schools to
um you know involve parents to provide
them the essential information so some
schools reached out to us it to us if we
have some fact sheets to be able to
provide in their community education and
we also provide that for the schools to
enhance the communication between the
schools and parents for them to
understand what yrbs is used for how how
questions are what questions are asked
to their kids
thank you represent Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
another question
and actually a comment first it would be
lovely if you could provide that fact
sheet to the committee please
um and my question is is this survey the
same in every state it comes from the
CDC and all the students across the
country who do it get the same questions
or is it modified at all thank you for
that question uh we have fact sheet here
but I don't think I have enough copy
copies um so that we will distribute
that later out in terms of questions for
ybs we have uh there is a very strict um
guidance how questions are selected uh
so first of all CDC will provide the
standard questions to all the states who
participate in yrbs and from the
standard questionnaires each state or
each jurisdiction needs to select a two
two-thirds questions from that standard
question which is about 60 Questions six
zero questions would be from the
standard questionnaires and we are not
allowed to change any wording even the
like a common over the period any
characters from those standard questions
and the rest of the questions like
one-third of questions about 30 or 40
questions uh states can choose from
their own
um uh State focused questions or state
added questions CDC also provides
um the optional modules uh for the state
you take into account
um so for those questions like the
sexual behaviors or drug use most of
them are from the standard
questionnaires so that the CDC that they
will have like a National Database or
National Data analysis to see how each
state is doing compared to the National
or compared to other states those
questions are standardized and and each
um States if they choose to have that
question that would be the same
questions as an among the nation
thank you that was helpful for the
questions representative uh try and then
Belcher anybody on that side
are you a male okay
thank you Mr chair and thank you for um
taking this question I sat in um not too
long ago on a meeting of social service
agencies uh last time the the study was
up and um they were complaining about
students who bragged about lying on the
survey and uh and I didn't know at this
point that it was required to take you
know I just thought well couldn't they
just have people opt in who are serious
about doing it and they said no we need
the numbers so that we can get the money
so I'm concerned that we are putting
social service agencies on a on a tight
wire you know they have to live with
perhaps invalid answers to survey just
to get the money so that maybe it's a
deeper problem than just opt-in or opt
out but I wonder if you had any thoughts
on whether there's more accurate
information if someone is opting in then
rather opting out
yeah so thank you for the question I
would like to answer for the first part
with the kids
um you know truthfully uh respond to the
questions or not
I don't deny that there are some
students they may not provided the truth
uh answer uh to the questions or they
might be you know kind of like not
taking it seriously
um
there we don't have a really kind of
like a number to see how it was a
percentage of kids are doing that but it
definitely there are some students
um when they when they take the survey
on their behaviors like that which I
just joke around I don't deny that part
however uh for the data analysis
standpoint
um yrbs is still valid even though there
are small percentage of students who
don't take Webbs seriously the majority
of students they do provide the truthful
answer and that is a very important for
us uh for yfs we do have two data cells
the first data set is assembling data
set which is randomly selected from all
the sensors for all the public schools
we pick the randomly pick several
classrooms from each schools and compile
the simple data set for that one we will
have a waiting uh process to provide the
confidence intervals for the future data
analysis to see if this
um if if it is stayed over the state um
uh from the time Trend to see if they
there is any significance increase or
decrease on the same topic so for that
simple data set uh because of the valid
scientific data analysis process it
actually
eliminated
um truthful answers and and during the
data analysis process we also have some
kind of editing if the kids not the kids
if it is a record answer that for the
first question it's like I never had sex
and the following question uh uh the
record shows that I have sex like every
day or I have sex with drugs then this
record will be invalid so we have some
kind of like a data um validation
process in place to to to see the group
of questions whether there's some kind
of conflicted answers if there's a
conflict answer then this this question
will be involved so in terms of if kids
tell lies how about it with the data
analysis be over or the estimate be we
are very confident that the ybs is is
very valid
um and provide a very reliable data
analysis across the time from the 10
years ago until now so that's what we
see from the data analysis part in terms
of up in the up down
um
country New Hampshire is taking opt out
approach to be opted in uh it will
increase loss of Burden not only on the
Stateside but also on the school
district side to collect each individual
opt-in forms and also to track students
hey do you want to you know turn in the
operating form uh and in order to take
the survey
um and if the
if the number of students who
participate in survey is less than the
response rate we have the sixty percent
six zero percent response rate in order
to make a valid data set for upping
options we do see
impact on the response rate may reduce
and for us to be able to get a good
sample size in order to provide more
accurate estimates so that is the
concern on the opening we may not be
able to get enough uh response in order
to meet the 60 response rate and not
only for the school data but also for
the entire State data
thank you very much uh represent Belcher
do you have a question yes thank you Mr
chair uh regarding this the bill and the
new language on lines 12 and 13
regarding exempting other surveys from
the CDC uh this sets off my Spidey
senses a little bit as far as far as
what might exist Does the department
have access to a comprehensive list of
surveys that the CDC might provide and
if so can you get that to the committee
so for the Department yrbs is the only
survey that we earn administered to the
high school students to public high
school students I'm not aware of other
um surveys to the public schools
students sponsored by CDC in the
department so I'm not able to answer
that part okay thank you
for the questions
I need just one point of clarification
here we have written in statutory
language opt out
we've had that discussion over every
year I've been here opt-in versus opt
out and I'm hearing that we may be able
to do opt in at the local school
district decides to do so is that
correct
if the school district decide to do
opt-in then they yes they can they can
address that if they want to provide
they want you to opt in and we will do
our best to
um you know Assist the school to get
updating but like what I mentioned
earlier it requires lots of resource and
time from the schools to do opt-in
that's why
um you know the current law allows yrbs
to remain up there which is a passive
parent consent but back to the uh
chairman your questions if the school
decide um you know after consideration
they really want you to opt in then yes
we will be able to do that however
the school may not be able to get their
school a report because of low response
rate if they take up in approach yes we
hear about that from the teacher
uh the one one other question I have for
you
um there's a bank of require there's a
required section uh questions that the
federal government or CDC has then
there's a bank of questions which are
optional
who decides which optional questions are
used is it HHS or is it Doe
so that is another good question so we
do collaborate with uh Department of
Education and also our internal program
areas like injury prevention program
um uh and uh Bureau of drug and alcohol
Services as well as the Community
Partners like Nam Nami New Hampshire
and also the trafficking
um excuse me the trafficking program and
also some School District to do the
question selection based on the
priorities so so it's not just a solo
decision from the Department to choose
the questions in the questionnaires is a
collaboration between the department and
department and also the local area and
also the local communities
yes representative Island thank you Mr
chairman I mean this has been an
interesting conversation about the
process of gathering the data my
question is what do you do with the data
that that's another good question as
well so from the department-wide we do
release the state level and also the
Public Health Region level because those
are from the simple size with um
confidence interval analysis in place we
release this data on our DHHS data
portal website and we also provide
static like PDF
data reporting on our website as well we
provided a school district their own
school or Community report to the
superintendent for them to understand
the survey result from their particular
scores however in that type of data set
it because it's not a weighted data set
which means there is no indicator to
show that this estimate this percentage
in the school is doing better or worse
compared to the state original so so we
we do not encourage the school to to
make that kind of statement and yet for
them to understand
what each individual questions what's
the percentage of the students in their
school respond to that question
for the data part there are several uh
parties that we use the data and if I
may excuse me I will need to check my
list here
um
so basically it's for the community
prevention so they're like mental health
questions
um about you know uh field Stat or feel
hopeless these type of questions and for
program areas such as injury prevention
program over over our mental health
Bureau or program areas they will use
this type of type of data and to work
with the communities or we work with the
region to put a resource and and provide
some kind of
assistance to the areas that will need
to have that they focused on so
so uh data is do IBS data is used by um
uh various programs or various
communities uh and also the school
district to look into their particular
area in terms of uh the specific survey
response and also might be able to
compare to the previous years on this on
on the um estimate for the same
questions
are there further questions from the
committee
thank you very much
thank you I don't believe we have any
other pink cards on that bill
it's about electronically up there but
they also talk about web down here so
foreign
thank you Mr chair and thank you to the
committee this is the first bill that
I'm introducing my first term so please
bear with me
um the background behind this is that
the New Hampshire constitution of course
uh recognizes the value of Education
um and uh you know tells us to cherish
it and a huge amount of what we do is
about that process
uh with anything where we wish to
achieve goals the proper approach is to
measure outcomes not inputs when we are
specifying healthy uh water uh we
specify the lead must be below this that
you know on and on and on with all the
details and we don't specify the inputs
we don't say that water treatment must
take at least uh you know 46 hours we
don't specify how much must be spent in
a similar way I think it is appropriate
that to make sure that education is done
correctly we allow an extra option and
right now there's two options there's at
least two Public Schools private schools
and homeschooling
um and uh you know one thing that we
measure with Public Schools is just
inputs that you must remain in your seat
for 12 years you must you know go
through a certain number of classes
um and there are some students uh who
are uh fortunate enough to be in
families where one of the parents can
take on homeschooling
um but if a child through no fault of
his own is not in such a family but
still uh believes that there's sort of
more that he can achieve in life and he
would like to accelerate his or her
education uh there's currently no option
to achieve that
um at least at the state level
so the intent behind this is to allow
any student who learns on his own uh to
prove that he has satisfied all of the
requirements
um of a public school education and thus
get his degree early and move on to
whatever is next for him or her whether
that's you know college or trade school
or something else
um
and uh that is the overall Gestalt of
The Proposal uh and one thing I would
like to speak to is concerns about
implementation or cost and the analysis
um you know does not say that there are
necessarily any cost but does note that
they are indeterminable
there is already a process for
assessment of students in schools and
how much they've attained and the
results of this are available per
account at the department of education's
website
um looking at it briefly this morning
there was something like two percent of
students who were assessed via existing
testing tests above the requirements 35
percent or so Statewide test at uh
requirements some percent test partially
hitting requirements so I phrased this
in a very open-minded way for the
Department of Education that they can
create whatever assessment tool that
they think is appropriate but certainly
one possible way to do it would be to
reuse exist testing assessment tests
these are already seen as a reasonably
appropriate tool because they're what we
are using to judge the performance of
the various high schools across the
state and so that is a way that I think
that this could be accomplished for
those few students who wish to opt into
a testing and potentially graduate ahead
of time with a certificate proving their
Mastery of subjects without spinning up
a huge new research projects or tests or
anything
and I welcome any questions
very much
.
we're looking at our education role CD
306 we talk about competencies and the
competencies are established by the
local school boards for courses and the
grad and the diploma is issued by a
local school district or High School
so are we talking about in here that the
the state of Alaska now excuse me I'm
great state that's a wonderful state
uh State of New Hampshire doe is going
to get into the business
of issuing graduation diplomas now and
taking that away from the local
uh that is a great question uh and I
understand the concern
um as written
um the bill says that the uh Department
of Education is in charge of that but I
would certainly be willing to submit a
Amendment uh clarifying that uh that the
uh Talent level uh government is
responsible for setting standards uh
probably relevant to their own uh
existing High School
well okay uh uh and I have one other
question here too on line 25
oh excuse me online 24 and child age 13
or older whether a citizen of New
Hampshire or or elsewhere
may take the test
are we talking about
a kid in Alaska
um I put this in here so that uh if
there was a case where uh two parents uh
shared custody of a child across the
state line that there would not be any
question that the student who spends
part of his time in New Hampshire uh
even if you know he didn't meet full
citizenship requirements basically just
to avoid that question and you know
that's certainly a question that uh
comes up in sort of voting discussions
and our college students residents or
citizens I just wanted to remove that uh
possible complexity thank you for other
questions representative Ellison oh
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I'm with bills on what
representative Ladd just asked asked
about whether if this was in place and
it would relate to a citizen of New
Hampshire or elsewhere
yeah
and were you know I've dealt a whole
throughout my career with high school
quality
programs and accelerated programs and so
on but by including elsewhere and I
understand your example
are we also looking at the possibility
of 50 Vermont students who are 13 coming
across the board and taking a test of 75
for Maine and 150 for Massachusetts
because they would qualify that is an
excellent question
um and and thank you for it and uh I
think that probably it deserves a
amendment to make sure that uh there was
at least some Nexus with residents in
New Hampshire
thank you
yes representative
good afternoon representative a couple
questions I may you made the comment
that 12 years of sitting in your seat
you realize that doesn't happen right
you realize that the kids are taking
external programs learn everywhere doing
internships local school systems allow
kids to uh earn enough graduation
credits sometimes in June year sometimes
a senior year so that accusation that
that stereotype would just sit there
back in 1950 is not really true in 19
2023 you understand that that's a good
question and uh I do understand that and
the point here is to uh make a Statewide
program so that a student who is in a
school system that is perhaps not so
enlightened as to have that codified or
has uh you know ambiguous or
inconsistent policies on it which is
something I've heard about
um would still have a option at the
state level so it doesn't you know
depend on a particular principle
uh you know when the the
you're using a couple of standardized
tests as at the as the base level
but a lot of the education that's
required for a high school diploma
that's locally created
um is much more uh comprehensive than
just the evaluation of the math of the
science of English literacy piece of a
student's high school diploma and that
would exclude that
um by just using those standardized
tests is a reason why you didn't make
some some preparation or allowance for
local impact there is
um the goal here is to empower students
and their families and if there was a
situation where a school had a local
requirement that you know all high
school students need four years or to
pass a certain test on the local County
history or something like that that
would then put the State Department of
Education in a position where it would
have to tailor tests each individual
Town knowing that you know oh in the
John Stark School District there's a
particular requirement I think that
um there is a baseline level of
Competency that we expect of a high
school graduate and that can be uh very
well approximated by a Statewide testing
um uh system and uh you know right now
we certainly allow people to achieve
competency in a lot of different ways if
someone is homeschooled uh in the town
of uh haniker
um that that they are not required to
pass any specific requirements that
might be present in the public schools
uh in Henniker and in a similar way here
um if a student proves that they are
competent at the skills expected of all
high school graduates uh yes just like
uh with other educational choices uh
either homeschooling or in a private
school they might not meet some
particular requirements that has been
imposed in that town and I see that as a
feature uh not a bug
thank you you're welcome further
question representative Cornell thank
you thank you for taking my question I I
guess I don't understand on page one
starting with line 27 about any
non-profit Institution
must accept a passing grade from
matriculation so this student wouldn't
have to apply to like the University of
New Hampshire and see if they got
accepted or not they would just
automatically have to be accepted that
is not the intent of it and I would be
happy to offer an amendment
um what I was aiming for there and you
know if you see the uh continuation on
line 31 shall not impose burdensome
regulations
um so so that speaks to the intent I'm
not saying uh that you are incorrect
about the uh bill as written and I'd be
happy to publish that to address that
concern
um the concern is uh that we would want
to make sure that universities did not
you know entertain some animus against
students who you know if there's some
very gifted student to it 15 or 16 tests
out that he is made to jump through
additional Hoops or de facto
discriminated against
yeah
thank you further question
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair I think this could
also possibly address the the concern of
the previous question so my um my
reading of this shows that a uh a test
that would be designed that would be
based on a passing score on the task
would be based on the average of high
school graduates my concern there would
obviously be unfortunately high school
graduates are often not found to be
competent when they go on to college
they require remediation so I'm not
necessarily opposed to the concept but
would it make sense to instead perhaps
Peg the testing requirement to something
like a higher percentile maybe an 80
percentile or something along those
lines to demonstrate that they have the
above average proficiency uh thank you
for the question that's a great question
um and I would certainly uh be amenable
to offering an amendment to assuage that
concern uh what I was aiming here was
just to you know in the original draft
to explain myself uh to make sure it was
clear that students wouldn't be taking
some sort of rubber stamp test that you
know gee I don't like high school let me
get out of here and uh that as a bare
minimum they would have to
um demonstrate the same level of
competence as uh other high schoolers
but the intent is largely to unburden uh
those students who are sort of eager for
more learning at an earlier age and feel
sort of stultified with the local
options and so the group that you know
sort of I have in mind is very
compatible with a you know at least
eighty percent so I'd be happy to offer
that Amendment thank you
I I have a question uh are you aware
that for our high school students we
have a phone call dual and concurrent
enrollment where we have many of our
students now graduating from high school
with at least one year possibly two
years of associate degree under their
bills I am aware and I believe that this
is complementary to that
um and there's no reason that that
couldn't continue I think that this does
address uh different concerns
thank you
further questions
thank you very much oh yeah
everyone's name
yeah thank you Mr chair
I can't quite figure out how to frame
this question so bear with me
I think in addition to what your
proposing testing for
students evolve between 13 and whenever
they more traditionally finish High
School
and I would just submit that there ought
to be some assessment of
maturity or Readiness to be in a
open environment
um thank you for the question uh I'd
like to point out that there is nothing
in here uh that is intended as I'm sorry
forget the term uh but the legal proof
of adulthood so if a student tested out
at the age of 13 and they said well you
know my mom and dad I'm headed off to
Caltech uh that is still a 13 year old
and Mom and Dad can say no you're not um
you know you're staying right here
because we know that you don't know how
to set your own bedtime or get dressed
and so uh you know
um citizens you know under the age of 18
are still minors until they become
adults
uh last question for me why did you set
the bar so low in terms of
it says accurately reflects the average
New Hampshire high school graduate the
average
um thank you for the question uh
representative Belcher asked the same
question
um and uh I I thought it was a an
excellent point and I said that I would
be happy to offer an amendment the and I
remind you that this is perhaps the
first bill that I have uh tried to draft
uh and I'm learning a lot
um but my intent there was to assuage
concerns in the opposite direction I was
coming at it from the perspective of you
know a teacher or members of the
committee might say so you know they
just have to take a test and you've got
no thoughts whatsoever about the
standards so I said oh you know that's
not true at all you've got to be at
least uh you know as good as the average
um but I think it's entirely within the
spirit of the bill to set that bar much
higher and I'd be happy to offer an
amendment for that and have you thought
of using an instrument like the act or
the SAT I uh specifically left it vague
as to implementation and said that that
was up to the director of the Department
of Education so that he could reuse an
existing test which might allow for you
know zero incremental cost if there's a
test that's already being offered he
could merely set a bar on that
thank you
for the questions thank you very much
okay so let's see I don't think you have
any of these so we're going to have them
all
I assume that's all the students which
we have here
you have a base no just press the button
go ahead
my name is Lyra Brown I live in
I support the bill
okay
um
is Kiba
related to you or no
Eva bomb
welcome
hello my name is Kiba balm I am from
Bedford New Hampshire thank you all for
listening I am in support of the bill
that is all thank you thank you very
much
there you go yeah hello my name is Edwin
Osborne I'm a homeschooler from Auburn
New Hampshire I support this Bill thank
you for your time
the one thing that really bothers me
about high school
is that it's pretty useless
specifically in this modern day and age
High School is used less as a way to
educate
children and more as either
babysitting or a way for children to
socialize with each other
now this is discouraging for those of us
who
want to excel want to do well in school
because we have to deal with
there's the whole distraction of the
public education just isn't great in
general
even like private schools or a
homeschool learning Cooperative they
could have issues like this and I think
for the benefit of the children of our
state it would be nice if we could test
out of high school that way we could go
about our you know our lives sooner we
could start going to college work more
which would be really nice I'd love to
um
say
yeah um
that's kind of what I have to say if
anyone has any questions well we thank
you very much for taking the time out of
your busy schedule today to come down
here appreciate it thank you
uh next person which we'll call is it
Riley
Riley what's your last name I'm trying
to read it here Glazer I'm sorry okay
foreign
my name is Riley Glaser I am 15 years
old I am from Derry New Hampshire and I
support this bill up until this year I
have been homeschooled for my entire
life
being homeschooled has allowed me to
Deep dive into more of my interests and
I was able to work and Excel at my own
pace
currently I am a student at spark
Academy of Advanced Technologies in
Manchester New Hampshire where I'm
taking college classes alongside my
normal high school classes as you
mentioned earlier with dual enrollment
dual dual enrollment I am currently a
straight A student I am a student
council an ambassador and on a state
qualifying Vex robotics team
I find it cumbersome to follow the
uh age requirements that the other
requirements of attendance despite
knowing the correct most of the
curriculum curriculum being taught I
believe students with the mental
fortitude to test out of high school
should be before the compulsory
attendance age or requirement ends
should have that opportunity allowing
students to acquire their High School
degree before the age of 18 enables them
to take advantage of things that require
a high school degree sooner and begin
their career goals
earlier in our society children are
infanticized instead of having
responsibilities and earning respect a
high school degree should be based off
of the level of knowledge you possess
instead of your age or credits earned I
would take advantage I would take
advantage of this opportunity by
continuing my deep dive into my
fascination with nuclear energy until I
am able to join the Navy's nuclear
energy technician program
the more time I'm able to spend
researching the more knowledge and the
more knowledge I can gain will set me
apart from other candidates in the
program
while I appreciate spark and its
opportunities I would rather have my
degree and spend more time taking
Unlimited College classes based on my
passion
in closing I believe that the bill is a
valuable opportunity for those who wish
to get a head start on being successful
to for being a successful adult thank
you for your time thank you Riley
Kitty
good afternoon my name is Kitty
michelotti I am a homeschool mom I am
also a teacher and a vice president of
latitude learning resources in Derry New
Hampshire and I have the privilege of
working with several very talented high
school students who for whatever reason
have not been successful
um
have not felt successful in traditional
learning environments and have come to
us to
try to learn in different ways and we
have found that many of these children
have come to us
with passions that they would like to
really explore but have been hindered by
some of the legislation that exists for
them
dual enrollment works sometimes
for some kiddos they just want to take
certain college classes and they aren't
a they're Limited in what they are
allowed to take they're Limited in the
requirements for taking them were they
able at the age of 13 or 14 or 15 to
pass an exam
have a high school degree they would be
able to start deep diving into those
passions while still living in their
parents homes I did not talk to any one
of my students this morning when I told
them I was coming up here to testify in
this bill not one of them said yes I'm
moving out they were just really excited
because often the kids who come to us
have come to us with really deep
passions and they just want to explore
them they just want to take as many art
classes as possible without having to
follow the high school standards that
were set forth by Harvard University
like 100 years ago we don't necessarily
need all these years of all these
classes we need to revamp the high
school curriculum and in the place of
doing that just let them test out of it
so they can start doing what they want
to do
one student who
opted not to come today but did give me
her opinion of the bill said she would
support this bill because prior to high
school she was a straight A student
she enjoyed learning she enjoyed her
classes and when she got to high school
the environment and the social pressure
was such that she began to fail all of
her classes
and she felt awful
and she didn't feel smart anymore she
didn't feel good about herself anymore
she now attends latitude and I'm so
grateful that she does she's now
teaching at latitude and I am incredibly
proud of her and
this bill would help children like her
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you thank you and
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh this is the last time I'll
be up here today sorry I know you've
seen me a lot
um but I I saw this bill come up on the
calendar last week and felt that I
really wanted to speak on this and and
give some thoughts uh this bill is
really designed to allow for students
who feel like they've already met the
requirements to have that chance to show
and to prove to the rest of us that they
they do understand the material and they
have mastered the content
um current state law mandates that they
must stay in the in the school system
until they either drop out or they
graduate and I think we've seen an
increasing number of people very
successful people especially in the tech
industry who were high school dropouts
and they dropped out largely because
they felt like they either weren't
learning enough in school they didn't
have enough time to really pursue their
passions uh issues with the
socialization aspect of school and we're
seeing a lot of these people go on to
very successful careers and it kind of
makes me wonder if these kids had had a
chance to take a test and opt out how
much more positive would their schooling
experience have been with these kids
rather than dropping out and either
pushing themselves and continuing on to
highly successful careers there's the
opposite of that there are the kids that
do drop out and we don't know where they
go after if these kids were given an
opportunity to show that they know the
content they understand it and uh could
test out of this I think it it would be
really great to see the change and I
think the difference that it makes in
some of these kids lives education is
really evolving at a rapid rate and
we're seeing new education opportunities
come up every year and so I think we
really do have a fairly significant
group of students more than just one or
two who would be looking for this as an
option so that they could either get
started on a career they could go on to
higher education but largely I think a
lot of these kids want to explore their
passions find out where they want to go
in life if they were able to graduate at
say 15 that gives a lot of time if you
want to focus on art or music or history
gives you a lot of time to pursue your
passions and kind of figure out where
you want to go in life
um just to give a couple of examples
I was looking through kind of the list
of companies that were started by kids
that were high school dropouts and I was
actually pretty surprised by some of the
the lists so we have the founders of
Wendy's Coca-Cola Tumblr the Holiday Inn
and McDonald's were all high school
dropouts and so these people are going
on to lead successful lives but they
clearly were in a position in high
school where they felt like their needs
weren't being met so if we could give
students like that the opportunity to
test out I think this would go a long
ways
um so I think that uh this is a great
opportunity like the bill sponsors
mentioned before there are some things
that he would address through the
committee so I think if we could work
out some of those amendments uh this
would be a great opportunity for these
kids
thank you are there any questions
now senior thank you very much
um
Mr fruit are you talking this bill
okay we have three eight here we've done
that one so we're on 399 now so you want
to talk at 399 yeah great thanks Jay
thank you Mr chairman and uh thanks to
the members of the committee for
allowing a couple of minutes to speak uh
first I want to acknowledge the prime
sponsors efforts uh to uh provide a
variety of Pathways toward graduation
and meet students needs to where they
are I also want to take a moment to
commend the students who attended today
to speak to this group it's a pretty
intimidating uh task it's intimidating
to me and I'm a little bit older than
most of them and so I want to just
acknowledge their courage
in the words of the Prime sponsor there
are several concerns and amendments that
would be required for this piece of
legislation to move forward we share a
number of the concerns that were brought
out I won't take the committee's time
reiterating those concerns but we would
suggest that this bill would need
further study either through interim
study or a fine name and expedient to
legislate depending on the the nature of
the committee but there are several um
factors that need to be considered
before this piece of legislation could
move forward really in the best
interests of kids
and I'll conclude with that thank you
very much any questions so the school
administrators association yes
representative leckis
um are there any that you could think of
that we haven't gone over just so we
make sure and cover them
issues I will I thank you for the
question representative like us I will
note those on the appropriate piece of
paper and get those to you thank you
very much thank you
further questions
thank you thank you and we have a card
here from the Becky Wilson from the
uh thank you chairman lad I almost said
good morning that just shows I don't
know it's okay here today
uh for the record Becky Wilson of New
Hampshire school boards Association uh
we will send in written testimony on
this bill we um appreciate obviously the
sponsors and of course the students for
bringing forward this bill to address a
very specific concern that they have and
while the bill in its current form does
not seem to directly relate to our local
school boards as uh the conversation has
been happening with the number of people
that have come to speak there's been
many amendments that have been mentioned
and I just wanted to put on to the
record that nhsba would certainly oppose
any amendments that would link this type
of program directly to students being
able to obtain some sort of uh test
result to get a local District
designed in a locally approved diploma
by their local school board school
boards invest an extraordinary amount of
time and care and development to
determine what their graduation
requirements are going to be at the
local level what the components are
Beyond or to incorporate the minimum
standards and we've spent a lot of time
over many many years and those of you
who've been on this committee for some
time looking at course competencies how
students show competency having multiple
opportunities to show their competency
in a variety of ways and certainly one a
one-time test would not meet for the
most part locally District designed
diploma requirements or graduation
requirements that would lead to
competency at that level so I'm happy to
take any questions and that will submit
some written testimony after thank you
very much are there any questions from
the committee
yes represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
if not the local
um school board and District who who
would you suggest might be issuing such
diplomas uh thank you for the question I
believe although you would have to ask
the sponsor of the bill that the current
bill reports of the Department of Ed
would be in charge of determining that
thank you you're welcome and Becky
during the years you've been in
education I know
quite a few
um have you ever dealt with Criterion
reference tests or tests which deal
specifically with curriculum that's
required and you have to have multiple
versions of these because you can't give
the same version I'll have you ever
thought about what the expense would be
to develop something like that or the
thank you for the question
um
I think over time and over many years of
looking at the way students show what
they know there's been a lot of
conversation about
um one-time tests and whether or not
that's a good valuation of what students
actually know at a given time or whether
or not they can apply the skills that
they know
yes we have many students who require
accommodations or modifications to
certain one-time tests some tests
depending on the purpose of why you're
giving the evaluation can and cannot be
modified based on that but again if
you're talking about a you know to try
to come up with some sort of equivalency
like the GED or the hiset exam or the
sat there are very limited modifications
and accommodations that can be made to
those things and it requires quite a bit
of documentation ahead of time if you
are going to make any requirements but
again those don't lead to a district
level diploma so that would be where we
would want to draw some sort of
Distinction thank you you're welcome
representative
thank you I don't know whether you know
the answer to this question but you
brought up the GED and it reminded me
that when my kids took their geds they
had to wait until their High School
their class in their High School would
have graduated but somebody said that
that had changed and I was wondering if
you knew what the current rules around
the gedr
uh thank you for the question I'm sorry
I can't see
sorry I can't see you
um I would have to look specifically for
those very further criteria for that
representative there are age
requirements I believe to take the high
set it's called now that's the noon
version of the GED
um and there may be some age
requirements for that or a certain
amount of time that you have to have
been enrolled at the high school level
or something to that effect before you
can take the GED but I would have to I
mean that I said I would have to check
on that
thank you I just I don't think it's
related to your cohort necessarily but I
do think it may be related to age okay
thank you I was just hoping you might
know I can look it up as soon as I get I
appreciated thank you thank you very
much Becky any further questions
have a good evening thank you
so this uh I think it's all the cards
we've had on that bill and we have two
cards in the next bill and then we're
done
um so we're going to close this hearing
.
okay
hb45 is establishing a committee to
study student loan forgiveness in New
Hampshire and I like to welcome
yeah you go ahead thank you so much Mr
chairman and uh members of the committee
uh today I'm introducing uh hb45 which
is a study committee to investigate
student loan debt in New Hampshire
uh so the state of New Hampshire has a
serious problem when it comes to what
its Workforce will look like in the next
15 years our Public University system is
one of the most expensive in the entire
country uh in our state our students are
paying the price at almost thirty
thousand dollars for in-state tuition
and fees
this disincentivizes students from
attending in-state universities and
contributes to our state's brain drain
High School grads are leaving our state
for cheaper options and out-of-state
students are finding it often unable uh
to live here because of High Cost of
Living uh
unfortunately uh
the state of New Hampshire is one of the
second oldest states in the nation and
our a lot of our Workforce will be
retiring in that next 15 years
while at the same time we are unable to
retain a lot of our students uh
but I I did this is not official data
but in a private study published in 2021
I saw that upwards of 75 percent of high
school grads could be leaving the state
for higher education elsewhere uh so it
would be a good point to have this study
committee look into exactly how many
students are leaving our state
uh with because of a lot of uh people
not wanting to necessarily stay here
after they uh leave College uh we need
to start looking at solutions for this
problem uh or else our state is going to
suffer uh because of a lock a loss of
Workforce
uh so I'm asking all of you to please
join me in supporting the creation of
the study committee so that we can
clarify the statistics and create a plan
that will benefit our state and our
students thank you thank you very much
[Music]
there you go good thank you chairman uh
good afternoon thank you for waiting
around
um but I have no problem with the
essence of what you're trying to do my
concern is the membership
um one of the things we found out a year
or two ago uh when they were looking at
student apps to finance the the broad
study of
expenses for Education whether the
college is public schools that they
needed some of the financial backgrounds
versus just legislators yeah uh and I
would think that would be uh
value here as well and the other one is
I would suspect we should be wonderful
to have someone from the University
level
um dealing with this all the time has a
better or an additional uh view so I'm
just I'm just suggesting if if you had
for a reason those were put in there or
you hadn't thought of them or you're
just happy with what you have
so uh of course representative Schultz
uh is the prime sponsor on this bill and
uh I don't know necessarily what her
intent was on that
um but I I again we could talk about an
amendment if that would uh be suitable
thank you chairman you're welcome
further questions from the committee yes
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair so just looking at
the idea of creating a student loan
forgiveness program my understanding of
loan forgiveness being that really the
pre the person who can forgive alone is
really the person who holds the loan
um given that the debt in these cases I
believe would be to universities because
somebody attends the university they
they take out the money to go there
I guess my question is is this is the
intent of this to be looking at things
like for instance the University of New
Hampshire last I looked as an endowment
of one billion dollars or is the intent
only to look at obtaining These funds
from taxpayers
um so that's a good question again the
point of a study committee is to look at
different uh approaches to this
legislation and so that we can try to
further questions
were you familiar are you familiar at
all with the granite guarantee program
a slightly yes I'm uh I'm currently a
student at UNH and uh I'm I'm on the
granite guarantee uh so it is a useful
program but it does not necessarily go
far enough for a lot of students
um so there are some additional concerns
uh because many of the people who are
above the threshold will uh actually be
a part of the uh the grant guarantee may
not necessarily be able to afford the
university system here
thank you
yes represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much representative Howard for uh
for for being with us this afternoon
um tangentially related to um uh to
hospital 45 uh uh was wondering if you
may have had a chance or maybe we'll
have a chance down the road to um to
take a look at some work that was done
um in a committee to study a state
guarantee of refinancing of student
loans and explore the possibility of tax
credits for businesses that offer
tuition forgiveness that's the title of
the study committee it was done back in
2019 and it came out of Senate Bill 139
so I just put it out there as reference
that that the committee did hear
substantial testimony again it's not
spot on to what you're looking at here
but there may be some relevant pieces
and obviously a lot has happened between
2019 and where we are today that
probably were not picked up on on during
during you know during the pandemic and
so uh so I think there may be some good
um good nuggets in here
um Senator chandley chaired that
committee and I served on it along with
uh representative Hill
yeah I I haven't had a chance to uh look
at that uh so if you'd be as kind enough
to send that over I appreciate it Happy
to do that thank you thanks
any further questions
thank you
foreign
good afternoon I figured you started
your day with me you might as well
finish with me as well
um I am representative Lauren selig from
Durham New Hampshire and I was speaking
with representative Howard about this
study committee and why it makes sense
um I happen to be the parent of a high
school senior and those of you who've
been through the process are probably
familiar with the joy of applications
which we have thankfully just completed
um my daughter is now filling out all
the applications for scholarship as well
um so we're a family that wouldn't
qualify for Granite State progress for
example
um my daughter is ultimately did submit
an application to the University of New
Hampshire
um she wasn't going to but she had no
hesitancy in applying to the universe to
one of the SUNY colleges
um and she applied to it because she
kept getting ads and then actually did
research and discovered that it would
cost her less paying full tuition as an
out-of-state student at any of the SUNY
colleges
including going for a master's degree I
believe then going for four years at the
University of New Hampshire living in my
house since we're only a mile away
now my daughter is currently taking
classes at UNH we have the benefit of
that as as Oyster River residents
but the reality is that the college
system in New Hampshire is the worst
funded State University in the country
um I happen to be working there when
their budget was cut in half by 50 I no
longer work for them as a result of that
um and so the the expectation that we
place on our young people and the burden
that we pay place on our young people to
pay tuition there and then also to
support the cost of living which in the
Seacoast of New Hampshire is some of the
highest in the country is unsustainable
and so I support the creation of the
study committee so that we can have a
more thorough and complete understanding
of the different aspects of the
penalties that this is causing about the
way in which it's leading to I mean I
would say if my my kiddos friends
um 95 are applying to out-of-state
schools
um and many of them are doing that in
order to save money
um and we obviously would rather keep
them keep them closer to home if they
would be willing to do that thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions
yes thank you Mr chair
um I I'm it's not immediately obvious to
me what the Nexus is between
um studying for striking student loans
versus increasing funding for
universities can you speak that just a
in in my personal opinion I think by
studying the way in which we loan money
to students and the way in which they
need support to repay those loans
um and where there is some State funding
and there are some federal grants and
other kinds of things that can be repaid
there are also a number of predatory
loans that that get to students but we
don't have a full understanding of the
different types of loans and the
different ways that students pay for
school and pay for all of their things
um and and we need a greater
understanding we we have um
two or three food pantries in Durham
um and one of them is primarily to serve
as students who can't afford to eat
while they go to school so I think
understanding really the level of debt
that our students carry that is pretty
unique to you to New Hampshire residents
is something we really need to be able
to understand and by having a study
committee that can look at those
different things and how loan
forgiveness can then allow them to go on
to living here hopefully being able to
buy a house and put down long-term
permanent routes to
um you know hopefully become teachers
and fulfill our our desperate need for
teachers in our school system or any of
the other jobs we have a very high job
vacancy rate and not a lot of people
left to keep filling those jobs
thank you further questioning
thank you very much thank you so much I
look forward to hearing all of you come
now Mr chair Mr chair motion to adjourn
okay